- Hey guys, do you like charity.
(all laughing)
- Gamers, we have a big announcement.
We are going to be doing
a 24 hour charity stream.
You heard that, right.
- So the world situation
kind of messed up right now
for all sorts of different reasons.
So we thought we would come together
stream for 24 hours to support
Doctors without borders
on our channel twitch channel.
twitch.tv/trashtastepodcast.
What are we gonna be doing
on that stream though?
Is the question, you're probably asking.
- Games.
We have a bunch of
different things planned,
including guests, games and humiliation,
and Joey will eat a ghost
pepper, maybe who knows. If we-
- Maybe.
- So make sure to open up that wallet,
to make sure that Joey can suffer.
- That's the reason we're
doing this. (chuckling)
- I'm not here for the charity.
I'm here to make Joey suffer.
- So the event will be starting 11:00 am,
Japan time on the 19th of March.
If you live anywhere else in the world,
here are some just basic time zones
that hopefully mood on is
putting on screen right now.
If not look it up yourself
on time converter.
But yeah, it'll be going on 24 hours
and we'll hopefully change
the world for the better,
even for a little bit.
- And on with the episode.
Wait, you're not gonna,
you're gonna solve it,
you're gonna solve it, Joey.
- No, because I fucking got
my yellow down here somehow.
- We can't start recordings
until Joey solves his rubics cube that's-
- It's fine's.
(Garnt laughing)
- I feel like I've got
like, I need a chip,
but like, it'll just-
(video fast-forwarding)
(light upbeat music)
- I completely forgot about
that we talked about it.
- All right there we go.
(upbeat light music)
- Welcome poop enthusiast
to another episode of Trash Taste Podcast.
I'm poop enthusiast one
with poop enthusiast-
- I'm not a poop enthusiast.
I'm a bidet enthusiast.
It's a difference.
- You literally just said.
God, I need to shit.
- No I don't. I need to.
- I hope that's the first,
second of this episode.
- The same way you need to-
I'm not getting into this guys.
I don't even wanna humor this clown.
(all laughing)
What you've been up to Joey.
- Pooping, pooping,
doing a lot of pooping.
- Not playing Final
Fantasy XIV like an idiot.
- For fuck sake Joey, for fuck sake Joey.
- I called you out right from the Get Go.
- Okay, okay, okay.
Like I remember, so we record the episode
where Joey's like,
Garnt don't play Final Fantasy XIV.
- [Joey] I think it was
like four weeks ago.
- Yeah, yeah and I'm like, okay Joey,
you're a good mate, I will trust you.
(Joey laughing)
And then what happens?
I get a condition in which
I need to stay in the house,
every day for about two weeks straight.
- [Joey] Okay.
- And I have nothing to do
because I'm not well enough to work.
So what I do first, I complete
13 Sentinels, which is-
- Oh, you finished it?
- [Garnt] I finished it. And then it was-
- Was it good?
- It was as fucking insane,
as you said it was.
- Good.
- And then I sit there,
twiddling my thumbs, going,
what now, what do I do now?
And then I look at the
date and I look at Twitter
and Final Fantasy XIV, comes
back on sale to the public.
And I'm just like, either
this is a sign from God
or the devil, either one.
- It's definitely the devil.
- Either one it's a sign.
- The only way to get you guys
to do anything is be like,
don't do this, don't, don't,
don't, don't watch this.
Don't play this game. You won't like it.
- Oh, was that the problem.
I was being too negative,
I had to do the opposite.
- I didn't watcha this week.
- Right.
- Just saying that's it.
That's it, that's it.
That's all I've to say.
- That's so funny, I didn't either.
- [Connor] That's crazy.
- Right.
- Shit couldn't be me.
- But yeah, I mean talking
about addiction Joey,
I mean, you recently going
to new Gotcha game as well.
- I did. Yeah.
We mentioned it very
briefly in the last episode.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's just like the week where we just,
what am I gonna start
heroine this week as well.
Like, well.
- Addicts anonymous.
- Everything just goes wrong this week.
- I mean, you've recently
just been addicted
to torturing yourself.
- I'm not addicted to it.
I wanna be done with it.
I'm tryna finish.
- You're definitely addicted to it.
- I'm not, I'm not, I'm not,
I don't like hurting myself.
- You're like a fucking mas-
well, you don't like hurting yourself,
you say after like your
10th Jump King stream.
- [Joey] It's like, you
know what I'll do it again?
- And then getting over it
and then the Pogo stick or-
- [Joey] I call it Pogo Stuck.
- Pogo Stuck, that's it.
- Well, first of all, I wanna clarify.
I don't enjoy hurting myself.
But, I enjoy challenge.
Sometimes challenges.
- Is that not just
mentally hurting yourself?
- Challenges require us to
go through some uncomfortable
feelings and challenges.
- I get that, you know but I think-
(Garnt laughing)
No, I get that sentiment.
But I think what makes
a challenge, you know,
satisfying is when you
do it every now and then.
You know, not every stream. (chuckling)
- Well you know what, I
had this like revelation.
While I was sitting there
and I was like, you know,
nobody bets an nine,
if you spend 1000 hours playing a FPS,
the moment you put 10 hours
into a shitty jumping game,
everyone's like, you've got a problem.
You know, what's up with that?
What do you mean?
- I still think putting a thousand hours
into an FBS is a problem.
- That's not a problem.
You don't know, you're not a gamer.
A thousand hours into an FPSs is not.
- Well over how long?
- I don't know, like a month.
- A month!
- Okay, no that is a problem.
That is a problem.
- Hold on, is there even a
thousand hours in a month?
(Garnt laughing)
- It would be just under I think.
- Because that would be a slight,
that would be a different
problem entirely if there wasn't.
- No, there is not. No.
No, there is. What am I saying?
- How many hours in a month?
- [Staff] 720 hours.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So this man is like in
the hyperbolic time chain.
- You can watch YouTube
at 1.5 times speed,
I FPS in 1.5 times.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I feel like FPS, I can get it,
'cause at least there's a bit more variety
than literally pressing a button
and pointing in a direction
and doing that for 10 hours straight.
- I've never had like my
wrists hurt before from gaming,
but doing the space bar games,
that hurts my wrist actually.
I dunno why that hurts.
- Yeah. That is carpal tunnel speed run.
- It's cause it's like the same action
over and over and over, right?
- Yeah. But it's good
content though, isn't it?
Not right now, it's terrible.
- It's good content.
No, no, watch.
- It's terrible right now.
It's like dementia stream.
I'm just going around
and doing the same thing
over and over again.
Not making any progress.
And but when I do beat it...
- That's what I'm saying
it's good content to watch,
not to do.
- Well it's a great YouTube highlight.
'Cause then it's done.
But when you're in the middle of it,
you're like, I don't
know if I can do this.
I'm gonna have a mental breakdown.
Don't know if like this can be done.
Mark did like seven YouTube
parts and just gave up.
- Like soul crushing, that is.
- I mean like it's good
content in the same way
that, you know Mr. Beast saying
PewDiePie a million times.
Whatever is good content, you know,
but you know, it's not
exactly what I'd call fun
and it's it's definitely suffering.
- That's not a J I can,
you know, bring back.
- So you know, I'd be
all the Jump King DLC,
I'm pretty gonna do the
other one at some point.
I might have done it by the
time this comes out who knows.
But I finished playing it
and I was like, oh my God, thank God,
the challenge is over, I can finally rest.
And I played Pokemon Arceus.
And like, it was kind of difficult,
but at no point did I ever
think, I can't do this,
like this is too much.
- [Joey] Well yeah of course,
it's a Pokemon game.
- And I missed that.
I missed that moment where I was like,
I don't know if I can do this,
like this is so difficult.
I need this.
- That's why you are a gamer and I'm not.
'Cause the moment I see a
part of a game where I'm like,
I can't do this, I'm like, guess I'll die.
(all laughing)
And I just don't do it.
- When I know someone
else has done something,
I'm like, well I can do it then.
- Why don't you play Sifu then?
- What's that?
- [Staff] Oh Sifu.
- Yeah Sifu, it's like a
new game that just came out,
which is kind of like based on, you know,
old school martial arts films.
And I've heard, it's like pretty damn hard
and it's pretty challenging.
It's like got, I mean I
haven't played it yet,
but I've seen other
streamers and other people
talk about it and I mean,
I don't want to use like
the Dark Soul analogy
because everyone uses the
fucking Dark Soul analogy.
Like, you know, difficulty
didn't exist before Dark Souls.
But I have heard that
it is a challenging game
to get through that has...
- [Joey] What I don't understand is-
- But I think like Dark Souls like nothing
compared to these rage games.
- Right, but what I don't understand is,
okay, you say you wanna
go for a challenge, right?
You don't wanna learn how to speed run.
- So speed run is a different
thing for me entirely.
- I don't think so. I think-
- [Joey] I think it's exactly the same.
- I think speed running
is closer to the shit
you're doing with Jump King and Pogo Stuck
than it is to do with like challenging,
you know, like just
mechanically challenging games.
- See, here's this is where
I think speed running for me
is like something that,
I mean, I've enjoyed it,
I've done it in the past,
speed run like Cuphead back when they had
an exploit in the game that they removed
and then it's like not really fun to do,
'cause it takes a lot longer now.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah. So I used to enjoy doing it,
but I found that the point was is like,
okay, let's say you get to a certain point
and you get to a really good time
and you start shaving off
like microseconds, right.
If you're a streamer and you
know, you wanna stream content,
it becomes really difficult to keep saying
like, this is content over and over again.
'Cause I'm not a speed runner.
I'm tryna make content, right.
- Right.
- And so if I'm tryna make
like a YouTube channel,
I'm tryna make highlights,
I can't be like Jump King
speed run highlights part 17.
Right, it just doesn't work like that.
And also with like saying my
Pogo Stuck or Jump King, right.
When, if I'm not speed running,
I tried speed running Jump King,
I got pretty good time, but in 12 minutes.
I think I can do better,
but again, I'd have to grind it a bunch
and it's not that entertaining.
But having a hard goal that is like,
you have done it, at this point
you're done, you can stop.
That's way more satisfying,
I think as a viewer to watch.
But also as a content creator,
it's a lot better for like
a narrative in a video
to have like this.
- I think it's pretty
simple to turn speed running
into content. You just-
- Well, you can,
- You just set yourself a hard target,
a hard and you get on it.
- Like when I say you should
be doing speed running content,
I don't mean like you should be going
for a fucking world record or anything.
But like, you know, like maybe
setting your goal to be like,
all right, if the world record
is like 10 minutes in this game.
Then, you know, my goal is
to get a PB of 15 minutes.
- Well then that sense then yeah.
You could do that.
I mean like Ladvick did it with like
some of the games that, he did like,
"Can you beat all Jump King in an hour?
For all three maps, you know
that that's interesting.
That's way more appealing to me,
than Trish tryna grinding
at the best time.
Very impressive with the
people who can do it.
I'm just not consistent enough.
I mean, it's fucking
hard. This like these.
- I don't know, man.
You've been pretty consistent
with all these like hard ass games.
- [Garnt] Yeah. I mean, you-
- I think you're like one step away.
- You seem to have found a niche of just,
yeah, I will just do
this one repetitive thing
that is this one mechanic in the game
and do it for 10 hours.
And I'm just like-
- That sounds exactly like
what a speed runner will do.
- 'Cause you know, it's
one of those things.
I keep saying that when I wanna buy time,
like one of those things.
- One of those things, one more thing.
- You basically can-
You need perseverance
to like an extreme level
for a lot of these games.
And I feel that most people
will just think this is stupid,
and I'm just like, I can see
like the micro improvements.
- Right.
- I feel that like tiny,
tiny improvements every time.
- I feel like this is
pure opium right now.
- No, it's not.
(Joey laughing)
- Okay, okay, okay.
- It's not.
You get better.
- Okay, okay.
'Cause like I get that for like say,
a mechanically intensive game, like Sifu,
you know like Dark Souls.
You would not be feeling this satisfied
if you weren't streaming this game.
- No, I would never do it alone.
- Exactly, right.
Because it isn't as satisfied.
Like you are finding like the micro,
like the micro thing that you find fun
about this game to try and
cope with how much of a like.
- How much of a shit time you're having.
- How much of a shit time
you're having while doing it.
But at least people
are watching you do it.
You know, I'm not.
- The chat is the silver
lining in this whole thing.
- But like, okay.
So like Jump King initially
I thought that it was dumb,
I thought it was stupid.
I thought it was unfair.
- Yeah.
- After playing it, I
think it's like amazing.
I feel like it's like, I'm not kidding.
It's an amazing game.
- Would you have said that
though if you hadn't beaten it?
- No, absolutely not.
I understand if you play it
and you think it's unfair,
I understand that.
But when you play those games
more and especially like,
okay, Pogo Stuck is no,
it's awful, awful game, not-
- You said that for
Jump King like literally
two, three weeks ago, right?
- No, I said Jump King was good.
- This is gonna be Polish
things when he beats Pogo Stuck.
And he's like best game ever made amazing.
- Jump King has the bang of visuals,
absolutely amazing sound.
- I do agree.
I do like the aesthetics of Jump King.
- It's like a it's a package, you know.
- Yeah.
Well, I will hold my-
I will reserve my opinions
because by the time
this episode comes out,
me and Joey will probably
have already done
our Jump King race.
- You try and beat it.
You gonna go for it.
- I mean, if we can.
Sure, but I think.
- I mean probably not on
that race, but personally.
If I start something,
I'm going to finish it.
- Yeah, yeah. I like if like-
I think this race is gonna be
the reason why I came
up with the race ideas
because, you know, I like myself enough
to not torture myself on
stream for entertainment.
So I was like-
- So he dragged me. He dragged me.
He dragged me.
- I'm like, I need someone
else to feel the pain with me.
- It was literally on camera.
You could, rewind by that.
He was like, Jump King sounds fun,
Garnt, do you wanna do Jump King?
- You wanna do too? You haven't played,
oh, what a coincidence.
Me neither.
But I think like, I mean,
we've probably already done it by the time
this episodes coming out.
But like as of right now,
I think it's like we're
giving ourselves like maybe
four hours just because Garnt
and I are incapable of streaming
for more than four hours in any game.
- I think 10 to 15 hours is a good range
of how long it might take you.
- All right. So that race,
we probably won't beat it.
But I think afterwards,
once we get the idea,
then we'll probably
like individually do it
and then try and beat it.
- It's weird, 'cause like games like that,
they like trick you into thinking
that the only progress that matters
is how far you've gotten.
Where it's like in games like
jump king and stuff like that,
you're gonna have to restart so many times
where it's not about how far you can get,
it's how many times can you do
all of the jumps to the point
where you felt perfect.
Like, can you do that more consistent?
- It kinda sounds like speed running.
- Kind of. Yeah, yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I mean it is.
- But at least with Jump
King, you get a mental break,
you know, you can stop for a moment
and you can kind of like, okay, right.
Poker Stuck doesn't stop.
The Pogo doesn't stop
moving. It's just awful.
- So like speed running.
- Yeah.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I mean the more I think about
it, the more I'm just like.
- The more I think about Pogo
Stuck is just a speed running.
- Yeah it's a speed running simulator.
- Try it, try it.
It's one of those games
that looks a lot easier
than it is for sure.
- I mean, I've done like
Bener 40's getting over.
- That's easy, that's nothing.
- And like coop and stuff like that.
I'm just like, even then I was just like.
- I thought Getting Over It was hard,
after playing these games,
Getting Over It is like medium,
not even like hard.
I mean I beat Getting
Over It in three hours.
My first time, so.
- I feel like you started
with Jump King and then you
like, I guess you downgraded
to Getting Over It.
- You get the mindset.
It's not about how good
you are at the games.
But getting the mindset
to improve at the games.
- I feel like I could.
I'll just go into like Zen
mode, zero ranging from me.
- You can't beat a game like
that while fucking being like.
- I did most of the time.
I was furious. It's so hyper man.
If you ever get to the top, the castles,
the soundtracks are like very hype.
- I can imagine it.
But like I see you guys
have been playing Pokemon
a lot as well.
I mean you've been playing in a bunch of.
You finished it?
- I didn't.
- He's finished like the main story.
- You finish it on stream
or finish it by yourself.
- I didn't get RCS,
that's all I have to do.
- Yeah. So there's like
a lot of post post game.
- So I've heard like
mixed things about RCS,
which is stop me from
getting it right now,
which is like, I've heard
like it's a really fun game,
but it's just a really empty world.
- I mean, it's the best Pokemon game
we've had in like five,
I don't fucking know a very long time.
- A very long time. I agree.
- That's like saying like,
this is the best Big Mac
I've ever had. It's
like, it's not that much.
- It's way better than
the Big Mac down the road.
- This isn't like saying
that like our queen of time
came before in like the Zelda, right?
This is, that we haven't
had a fresh Pokemon game
in a long time.
I know this is old news by
the time this has come out.
But I think it's still good to retro.
- I mean, I'm still playing it.
I'm playing all the
post game and I'm doing
all the side quest and everything
'cause I'm just that kind of gamer.
- It's a hard Pokemon game.
- It gets very hard.
Some of the battles are hard as fuck.
- Yeah, it's kind of annoying.
'Cause it feels like they revolutionized
what they needed to.
And somehow just completely like,
did stupid choices for certain things.
They just like make
battles for like the first,
like two thirds of the game, just like,
way too easy.
- [Joey] Way too easy.
- Right and then randomly they're like,
how about we just fuck you.
And they just start making
them really fucking hard.
- But the thing that I notice is that
it's not just the fact that
there's just this immediate jump
in the levels of the Pokemon.
But like I feel out of
all the Pokemon games,
the AI in this game is so fucking gearing.
- [Connor] Oh yeah. It's smart.
- They're very, very smart.
So it's like they do some
moves where I'm just like,
that's like competitive level Pokemon.
And I'm just getting,
'cause like I'm so used to,
you know, fighting like
really dumb end PCs
in Pokemon games, right.
Like in all the main light Pokemon games.
And this time around, it's like,
we're playing 5D chess now.
And then it just gets fucked.
- Yeah, I felt like in
previous Pokemon games,
just knowing the typings
of the Pokemon was enough
to like easily comfortably get you.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- Right.
- Whereas the points in
this game, I was like,
I know all the typings, I
just can't beat this one guy.
Like there's this one fight in the game,
it's very difficult.
And it took me like 10 attempts to do.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah.
- Very frustrating.
- So you can't just
like autopilot your way
through the game anymore.
- You do have to, after a
certain point in the game,
if you wanna beat a certain
fight, you do have to like
think and grind and actually I doubt
you'll do it first time,
it's very difficult.
- I managed to do it first time,
but only because my chat was like,
there's a hard as fuck fight coming up.
So you better at least like prepare
and I'm like, guys come
on, fucking easy whatever.
And then I do it, I almost fucking died,
I was like, oh, okay.
I should probably go grind a little. Yeah.
But like, look I completely get
why people don't wanna touch the game
because when I first booted up the game,
I was like, God this
looks like a PS two game.
- [Connor] It doesn't look
great and it doesn't run great.
- Graphically, it doesn't look great.
It runs like shit a lot of the times,
especially if you're like playing
it through a capture card,
like it's a little bit better,
I play it a little bit on
stream, like on the switch
and it plays okay.
It's still not amazing.
Like it's still nowhere
near as like, you know,
fucking Mario Odyssey
levels of like frame rate
or anything like that.
But I think you get over it very quickly
because the gameplay just
so refreshing and fun
and like, yeah, I get the world is like
empty or whatever, but-
- People said it was
empty, but there's like,
I mean the Pokemon are
the thing that you give.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know, I hated having to collect
these fucking berries in
the trees all the time.
- Yeah. I kept running outta poker balls.
It was really annoying.
- It's like, you know, you
could like go on a mount,
but you couldn't collect stuff on a mount,
so you had to get off
it to collect the stuff
and then immediately get back on it.
- You can collect stuff on a mount.
- No you can't. Oh no, no you can't.
No you can't.
- You can.
- No you have to get off the mount.
- Well, oh, like throwing it outta tree.
Oh, I thought you meant just
like stuff on the ground.
- Oh, stuff on the ground. Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah. Okay sorry my bad.
- I was like, what, what.
(Joey laughing)
But like the best part of the
game is just catching Pokemon.
They actually like recaptured
that joy of being tan again.
- The moment when you
can just like be hiding
in a little shrub and you
just fucking yeet a poker ball
just across the field and
you catch that Pokemon
without anyone noticing you,
is like the best feeling every time.
- And also like, you can,
like, let's say your level 30,
you can catch a level 70
Pokemon with enough persistence.
If you just get very, very lucky.
Which is really fun.
And it's like, really like,
oh my God, this is so exciting.
- It's a hype moment when
you like catch level 70
at level 30.
- But you can't control it.
But I mean, it's still like really cool,
so you can have these
really strong Pokemon.
I felt like they had a
good range of Pokemon.
They didn't just choose
the normal ones you expect.
I don't know, I think
people were a bit too harsh
on it I think.
- I agree.
Yeah, I think people
were a little bit too.
Yeah, because I mean, I get
the whole argument of like,
oh, it's Nintendo it's game freak.
You know, they should have
a billion gazillion dollars
to put into, you know,
making a smooth game
and giving it the best graphics.
But it's like, I don't know.
I personally think that
like the graphical choice,
I guess, that they went
for like fit the story.
- I don't really care
about graphics that much.
- [Joey] Me neither, honestly.
- Honestly, like-
- I dunno either, but they
were noticeably lacking
I'd say.
It wasn't that they weren't
good, it's that they were like,
oh, okay.
- There were definitely
some moments where I'm like,
oh, that tree in the distance
is freaking out for no reason.
Let's just ignore that. (chuckling)
- I thought those good
quality of life changes.
I don't know, it's Pokemon, right.
So when they take one step forward
and then they just tear their leg off.
That's what they do.
Like they, the moment
they have something good,
they start just fucking it up.
And I bet, I hope that we
get more games like this.
'Cause they basically made it so that
you don't need to battle.
But also the battling is way smoother,
there's not this animation bullshit,
it's like that it happens,
you know, you can run around,
you can, it's good.
But I know it's Pokemon.
So they're gonna be like, all right,
now let's just get rid of that,
let's not do that anymore.
And it's like, why what's wrong with you?
I really hope that I'm wrong.
- Enough fans need to
make it fucking operol
for them to like bring
back a certain thing.
- I don't know.
I feel like Pokemon fans are loud as fuck.
I feel like it's just Pokemon
company doing their own thing.
- Yeah, that's usually.
Like it it's just the
Pokemon company being like,
we can make whatever fuck we want.
We know you'll buy it.
- Yeah. I mean they will.
I mean Pokemon's like the most profitable,
like franchise of all time
for like a reason, right.
- It's a fun game though.
I'd say, I think I'd said it
was six or seven out of 10.
- Six or seven.
- I'd give it like, yeah,
seven or eight. I'd say it.
It's a really refreshing.
- Considering I bought the
pearl and diamond remake
and I have barely had the motivation
to even put it in my switch.
I think that says a lot.
- I know it's weird for me right
because as someone who
doesn't really have to time
to play games, I like,
if something's not like a nine or a 10,
I very rarely go out and play it,
unless I'm streaming it or making content
or something like that.
- But how would you know
if it's a nine or a 10,
if you don't play it.
- Normally I just watch reviews
and listen to recommendations.
- I don't know if you've
heard of a thing called IGN.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Hopefully I'm gonna think
order medic critic obviously,
obviously the most trustable source.
- So basically the only
game Garnt has ever played
is Awkward Enough Time.
(Garnt laughing)
- It is a light novel though, as well.
So that might get you into it.
And you never shut the fuck up.
- [Joey] There's a lot of dialogue.
- It's really weird, 'cause it's like,
it takes me a lot to get
into a game sometimes,
it's like, I've tried to
really like narrowed down
what my taste in video games is
and the more I think about
it, the more I'm just like,
I have no idea. 'Cause like, okay,
so like we've Final
Fantasy XIV for example.
Like, so I was playing that like
a little here and there
during when I was ill, right.
And I remember literally
yesterday, literally yesterday
we were in the lift and I turned to Terry.
I'm like, Joey, gotta be honest with you
start Final Fantasy XIV, right.
But you don't need to worry Joey.
I'm like it's not addicting at all.
Like I'm like, I played
it, I've stopped myself.
I'm good. I'm good.
- I shook his hand and everything to him.
- Yeah, he shook my hand
and then I went home
and I'm just like, I don't
really have anything to do,
maybe I'll just like, 'cause the thing is,
it's just a nice comfort
game for me to like zone out
and just, you know, tap buttons.
And then so I boot it up and
then I get into like my first
like big boss battle, like big raid.
And then I remember finishing the raid.
I was like, oh no, that was really fun.
That was really fucking fun.
- I need you to,
I wanna take back that
handshake I gave you that night.
'Cause I thought we had
like established something,
you know, there was a
trust that was formed there
and he just ripped it away.
- I was just like,
oh, I really, really wanna
continue playing now,
I look at the clock,
I'm like, it's midnight
we gotta Trash Taste
recording in the morning.
I'm like, I'd go for another two hours.
(Joey laughing)
And again another hour or two.
I can squeeze, how much sleep do I need?
And like, 'cause here's the thing.
I've never really gone to MMOs, right.
I never went through a
phase where I got addicted
to RuneScape.
I was gonna say Runecraft, then RuneScape
or WoW whatever like that.
So this is like my first proper MMO.
And like, I wasn't really into it
because I thought like I didn't
really enjoy the gameplay
because like the battle
system for Final Fantasy,
especially at the beginning
was like really fucking basic.
It's like just point at
something and tap a button
and do like a basic three
hit combo and then that's it.
And I was like, you know,
I'm here for the story.
I'm gonna stick here for the story.
But then I experienced the
first raid, I was like,
you know, that was pretty damn fun.
And I'm scared for
myself now. I don't know.
It's been a while since
I've had the experience
of just having a moment in a
game and just having like this,
like I guess like it felt
like an ember had been lit,
just like, I wanna experience that again.
- That's what I'm saying man,
like MMOs are a lot like,
like quick sand.
Where it's like, the more you try to quit,
the more you just get sucked in.
- I'm glad I got it out of
me when I was like 14, 15.
I don't really have an
urge to play MMOs at all.
- Me neither.
- Yeah, I mean like what did
you guys find addicting about
MMOs when you got into it?
- I think the number one
thing that got me addicted,
which I'm glad you haven't
experienced yet personally
is when you have like a
large group of friends
that you see often who also play it.
Where like, it's just like
I have like a group of like
three or four mates, like
during the RuneScape era
or like the Maple Story
era that I could just like
ring up on Skype and
just be like, all right
SO, Sesh for like seven hours
and like, yeah, let's do it.
And then you just play it
while you're in a conversation
and it's the best way to kill time.
But at the same time,
it's like you finish
that seven hour session
and you're like, what have I just done?
- Yeah, I think it's a
game where like the goals
or for me at least felt like they were,
there's never ending supply of goals.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Whereas like a game, like,
I don't know if I do this,
the campaign in a card or something,
it's say I'm done in then hours.
But RuneScape, it's
just like never ending.
And every time I hit a milestone
and I got more cool quests I could do
and I thought, wow, that's so sick.
Oh, I got this really badass item. Okay.
And so like, every time you
are grinding towards something.
You always just kind of
unlock these cool things
that were just enough serotonin boost
to keep you being like invested a lot.
- And then even when you finish through
like all those side quests, for example.
You see one player that
just walks past your plan,
you go, I want what he has.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- How do I get that?
And then now your quest is to be that guy.
It just never ends.
- And then also like,
I don't know if you can
do this in Final Fantasy,
but in RuneScape you could
lose like all your stuff.
- Really?
- Yeah, you could just lose all your game.
- By dying.
- Yeah by getting killed.
- By dying, okay.
I've died fucked of on it and
lost nothing. So thanks a lot.
- See, there you go.
That's like Pussy MMO.
(Joey laughing)
Hold in your hand.
- I feel like I wouldn't
be able to get into
like RuneScape or WoW then
because like one of the
big factors I feel look
into video games is like, I
need a reason to keep playing.
And most of that reason is storyline.
Like gameplay loop a lot of the time,
that's not enough of a
reason to keep me invested in
me invested in the game
for like long term.
Having said that your
thing about the Maze thing,
like when I was doing this boss battle,
I was like,
I wonder how fun this would
be with friends to do it
at the same time.(laughing)
- You're gonna be that guy who're like,
Garnt can't join us today cause
he has a raid or something.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah. He has an event raid.
That's only available during these hours.
- But yeah. I mean, this
is I guess the start
of I don't know what, yeah.
it just, maybe I might
stream it who knows.
- You know how before
you were saying that like
viewers of Trash Taste could tell
when we record these
episodes based on my hair.
Then now they're gonna be able to tell
based on the size of his eye bags
that are gonna be falling
from endless nights
of Final Fantasy XIV.
It's like, oh man they're
like this far down now,
he is like, you finish three raids Garnt.
- I think I also stay away from them
'cause my little brother was like
addicted to World of Warcraft.
And I could like,
just see how much he would play it
and it onto like no avail.
- [Joey] Yeah exactly.
- At the end of it, he was just like,
yeah, it wasn't that fun.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
After like years of playing.
- Well of course it's like, you know,
every fucking league player
or like Overwatch player that
invests way too much time
into this one game.
And of course what'd you
have to show for it well,
I reach diamond, you know.
- Usually what you have to show for it
can be summed up in one sentence.
It's like, yeah, it was, fun.
- Why is it that playing like
a hundred games for 10 hours
is like seen as okay.
But playing one game for a
thousand hours is like no.
- Double standards right?
- What society.
- We live in a society.
- That's fucked up, we live
in a society that ain't right.
- I don't know.
I just feel like there are
just so many games nowadays
that are available even if
like you have nothing to,
even if you feel like
you have nothing to play
or no big releases have come out,
you just go through your
fucking steam library, right.
My steam library is like, my-
- God, I have not
touched my steam library.
That's what I think to myself.
Right, I'm like, okay, so
I just finished this game.
Go when I finished 13 sentls, for example.
I was like, all right,
cool. I finished that game.
Fuck now what do I wanna play?
Normally people be like,
oh, I have a, fuck like
300 games of my steam
that I haven't even like installed at all.
Nope, instead I go to
the PlayStation store.
I download Sona three knock turn.
(all laughing)
And I was like, yeah let's
play this. (laughing)
And now I'm just playing that.
- Oh my gosh.
- See, I would rather have
one game that I'm really into
than a hundred games
that I mildly enjoyed.
You know, like to me, like
Pokemon RCS for example,
seems like kind of fun, but
it doesn't seem like a game
that I could like properly,
like throw myself into,
you know, it's weird for
me cause I'd rather be like
fully invested in just
like emotionally invested
in one like a few things.
- Why Final Fantasy?
Why did that get you emotionally.
- Because I heard from every person
who fucking talks about Final Fantasy,
that has a good story and I-
- [Joey] To be fair as much as I-
- But I heard about like NFTs are great.
If you just listen NFT reviews.
That's, you know, if you're asking addicts
why something's great,
it's probably not a good,
like did you talk to people who played it
and didn't like it.
(Connor laughing)
- That there's the catch.
Everyone who's played it
has said it's a good game.
It's just like, for example like,
when I played the Trial,
when it first came out,
I'll admit it's a great fucking game.
But I like used a hundred
percent of my brain power
to be like, you know what, I
know it's a fun game brain,
but you are not going to play it.
- I feel like if you are
only talking to people
who are into it, oh they
seem to all like it.
Yeah, 'cause they're into it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
But that's the thing,
everyone at least around me that I know
that has, or is playing
14 has said nothing
but good things about it.
- Yeah, I feel like there
are some people who are like
maybe, you know, people who are-
for example, addicted to
League or addicted to Overwatch
where they're like, no
just don't get into it.
You don't have fun with this game.
- Yeah but that's cause
you're in you know,
every game has its life graph, right.
Final fantasy is just
in it's like its infancy
compared to League.
We have like 15 years or
no, 10 plus years of League
of don't do it, don't do it.
We know time has proven
us, history has taught us.
- Well 14 at this rate might
also gets to that point.
- Look I dunno if this
will be a purely age thing,
but I'm in for the story
and once I do the story,
I won't really have any other
reason to continue playing it.
- They're always coming
out with another expansion.
It doesn't end.
- (chuckling) Well, you know.
- Is that micro transactions in it.
- Is it?
- I haven't seen any.
- Is it micro transactions or expansion.
- [Staff] (indistinct)
- Oh, okay. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's a Japanese game of course there's
migration transaction.
- Well like you, from what I understand,
you pay for like any new expansion
which is basically like
another part of the storyline.
- I mean, WoW was the same as well right?
You had to pay for expansions?
- WoW's a subscription service, right?
- Yeah, it was a monthly plus
you had to pay for expansions,
right, yeah, yeah.
- [Staff] And now you
have to pay for coins
or something like.
- Yeah. I mean.
- Yeah, I don't know too
much about the MMO world.
- That's why I play Gotcha,
where I can choose to put money in.
(all laughing)
It's not a requirement.
- It's like the cancer cell
fighting the aids cell at this point.
You know it's better
than MMOs, Gotcha games.
- Everyone's into that
Lostark aren't they?
- Yeah. Everyone's into Lostark.
- I don't know what it is.
I'm too scared to ask this.
- I've seen a lot of my
friends play it on stream
and I'm like, okay, that looks fun.
But right now I'm into Heaven Burns Red.
So I'm just playing that.
I mean for the story.
- This episode is
sponsored by Express VPN.
- When you use bathroom
you always close the
door behind you right?
- [Joey] Of course.
- Right Connor right.
- I don't, I don't.
- Of course, of course.
- So why would you let
people look in on you
when you go online.
Using the internet without Express VPN,
is like going to the bathroom
and not closing the door.
- [Connor] Did you know that
your internet service provider
knows every single website you visit?
- And what's worse is that
they can sell this information
to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data
to target you.
(Joey exclaiming)
But gentlemen, gentlemen, gentlemen,
Express VPN puts a stop to this.
It creates a secure encrypted
channel between your device
and the internet so that
your online activity
can't be seen by anyone.
- I use Express VPN on all my devices
because it works on everything,
phones, laptops, even routers.
So everyone who shares your
wifi can still be protected,
even if they don't have
Express VPN themselves.
And the best part is using Express VPN
is as easy as closing the bathroom door.
You just fire up the app,
click one button and
boom you're protected.
- So if you're like me
and you believe your online
activity is your business
secure yourself today,
by going to expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
use my exclusive link E X P
R E S S vpn.com/trashtaste.
And you can get an extra
three months for free.
- That's Expressvpnn.com/trashtaste
back to the episode.
- You know what non-toxic
game I introduced
these gamers to today.
Wordle. (laughing)
- Oh yeah.
I finally, oh my God, dude.
It was like a weight
lifted off my shoulders
because for months now,
every time I go onto Twitter,
like five people on my
timeline are just like
tweeting out these like fucking squares.
It's like these yellow and green squares.
- I'm just like, is this like
higher glitch or something
like what's going on?
- I'm like, is this like
an invitation to a cult
or something like.
Do I have to decipher this
and then I joined like
the fucking, (laughing)
the stone smiths or whatever
the fuck it's called.
- [Connor] Stone Mason.
- Stone Mason that's it.
- I was almost more confused
once Garnt had actually
explained it to me.
'Cause I was like, why are
people tweeting this out?
It didn't make any sense.
- Admittedly it's good.
It's like a good, like little time waster
because there's only one word a day.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I think it's like the marketing strap.
I dunno if feels like on purpose,
but it was like fucking five head right.
Because everyone gets
the same word every day
and you only get one word a day right.
And when you tweet it out, it's
kind of like, I don't know,
it's kind of like tweeting out
like a gold star or something
or like an achievement
in a video game right.
- It's like, what is the
equivalent of being like,
yeah so yesterday I beat
level 127 of Candy Crush
in like two minutes, get on my level.
- I don't tweet it out.
I just do it just to
prove to all the tweets
that I see that I can do it every day.
- Yeah I sat there and I was like,
but why would anyone tweet this out?
'Cause I guessed a five
letter word correctly.
I just couldn't understand
it. I am I missing something?
Like, is it-
- No.
- What about it is an achievement?
I'm not attacking anyone
who has tweeted out
you can do whatever fuck
you want on Twitter.
There's some people who
were like, they were like,
I don't know, pretty like big accounts.
I'm like, why the you
tweeting about Wordle?
- Yeah, I had like two or
three people I followed
that I think were like actively
at one point were like, what
the fuck is this Wordle shit.
I don't fucking know.
And then like a week later they're like,
got in two tries baby.
I was like, oh no.
Is this Final Fantasy XIV all over again?
- No, because like, the
thing I don't understand
about how this trend started is like,
what made people want to
tweet at the first place.
- Who sits and it's like,
y'all gotta (indistinct)
- You know, when you're
like have an app open
and you get like that
notification, which is like,
would you like to review this app?
And then post on your timeline.
- Share your results.
- Yeah, share your results.
Who's ever shared the
results before Wordle existed
and what was the black magic
that Wordle put on their users
to make people want to share the results.
- Like when I get like a
high school on temple run,
I'm not sharing that, 'cause
it's a fucking mobile game.
- Share it to your
Facebook friends is like,
no I don't think I will.
- Everyone, who's like, yo Facebook sucks,
like yeah, no Twitter is
slowly becoming Facebook.
This is what boomers do,
this is what they do.
They're like, look what
I got in Farmville.
It's like what? We're no better than them.
- But like what are the,
it's like the equivalent
of like having a newspaper
with like the crossword
and like your grandpa comes and shows you,
oh, look at this completed crossword.
- Crosswords are too hard.
- Yeah, yeah. Crossword way harder.
- It went from crosswords to
like newspaper Sudoku puzzles,
and then it's now Wordle.
Cause what I was surprised
the most about Wordle
was that I thought it was like an app.
Like all those other ones right.
But then I realized it's
the fucking New York times.
It's just the thing
that New York Times had.
- Just like, I remember Joey's searching
for like the app stores.
Like no you just type it in the brand.
- And I'm like, why is there
like Russian apps coming up
on my thing? Like is this-
- Wordle.
- Yeah Wordle.
(imitating Russian accent)
- [Staff] That's why New
York times bought it.
- Yeah they bought it.
- Okay. Big brain.
- Yeah. I remember I tweeted ages ago.
I was like, I don't know what Wordle is
and it's been so long ago
I was too afraid to ask.
- At least, well, I mean
you weren't afraid to ask
'cause you tweeted it out.
I was actually afraid to
ask, I don't even wanna,
I'm keeping this in the draft bro,
I'm not fucking tweeting that.
- I mean like, I tried my
longest like just not Google it.
- I like refuse to give it the attention.
This is gonna die in a
week. I'm not gonna look up.
- And then like, I was just like,
it's something that's going
to die in a week or something.
I don't fucking know. I'll
let Twitter burn itself out.
- So I didn't even know
what it was called.
So like I got this close
to like going on to Google
and being like green and yellow squares
on my Twitter timeline.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Yeah. Then I gave it a week.
Didn't die. Give it two weeks.
And people were still posting about it
and I'm just like, okay, I'm
just curious, just curious.
- Okay, so how long have
you been doing Wordle now?
- For like, for like a good
week or something. Just-
- Every day you just log on.
- Whenever I remember to,
normally when I see it pop up my timeline,
I'm like fuck you.
- [Joey] That's the reminder.
- Fuck You.
- [Staff] You look at this man right here.
(staff howling)
(Garnt laughing)
Great now our fucking staff
members are getting into it.
- You got it in three tries?
- Yo David, how many tries
did you get? Three, okay fuck.
- It took me four. Damn bigger brain.
- Take these guys for helping each other.
They got a single letter for free.
- He gave me A, that's hard.
- Yeah he gave me M.
- No, I gave you M in the
right spot. Come on Joey.
Acting like didn't help.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'm just like these boys are cheating.
This is an individual game,
you know you're not
supposed to help each other.
- Should play a Babble Royale though.
Have you seen that game?
- What's that?
- Scrabble Battle Royale.
- Oh yeah. I've heard of it.
- That was fun.
- I just really miss playing Scrabble.
Is that boomer of me to say.
- I never played a game of Scrabble.
- You've never played Scrabble?
- [Connor] No.
- Dude,
like people keep saying like, oh yeah,
UNO is a friendshipender, Monopoli, no,
Scrabble is the real friendshipender.
You know, your friendship is fucked,
when you're fighting with
a dictionary in your hand.
Like that's when you know
your friendship is in
the dire straight, right.
That's like, oh, we got a problem here.
- There are a lot of like
three and two letter words
that you're like, this is a word.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
And then when, like, you
know and then the argument
always comes longer being like,
well, if it's like a commonly used word
that's not an a dictionary is it allowed?
Like, am I allowed to use the word Yeet.
Because you know why is
like a lot of points,
it's not an a dictionary though.
And then when the friendships just crack,
we should do it on stream.
- I think VAX and anti-VAX
is in the dictionary now.
There's a lot of double X, double X there.
It's a lot of points you can get on.
- [Joey] V and an X? God damn.
- Everyone's gonna be like scrambling
for those V and X's now man.
- Are we doing a dictionary
one or a non dictionary one?
'Cause I thought dictionaries
weren't allowed in Scrabble.
- You say it like it's a speed runner.
(all laughing)
- It's like a math thing.
Calculator or no calculator.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Dictionary run.
- Scrabble dictionary run.
- Sorry I'm only a dictionary runner.
I dunno the stats for
a non dictionary one.
(Garnt laughing)
No, we should definitely do a Scrabble
game on after doc because
that, honestly like
it's legitimately fun,
I'm not just saying like,
I'm not being a boomer here,
like it's legitimately fun.
- You seem to like word games though.
'Cause I remember you would
countdown with just like,
yo, this game exists,
yo, how have I never
play this game before?
- Yeah, like countdown
I had a lot of fun in
and you got me into Wordle.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It's all word games, dude.
I dunno it's just something fun about,
but then again, like
recently I have been getting
quite boomer.
- Yeah, I did see your video,
which is like, am I getting too old?
And I remember seeing that
and I'm just like, fuck
you Joey, fuck you.
- [Joey] What are you my comment section?
- He's 27, he's like I'm dying
guys. Shut the fuck up Joey.
- Like if you are old
Joey, then what am I?
- See, this is how you know,
these boys didn't
actually watch the video.
- No, I did watch the video.
I did watch the video.
- No, because I recently
got back into golf
and I was like, my God,
that is the most boomer
thing I've ever done.
- See, I don't think
golf is a boomer thing.
- It's a privilege
thing, It's a difference.
- It's a privilege boomer thing.
- Yeah, if you are broke,
you can't be playing golf.
That's just facts.
- That is true. That is true.
- It's just, golf isn't a boomer thing.
Golf is just a,
you have a lot of disposable
income kind of thing.
- I think it's just, yeah,
but that's the thing, right.
I think a lot of people
mistake it as a boomer thing
because it's played by a lot of people
of the older generation.
But that's because they have
the time and the money now.
And also, you know, relatively speaking
golf doesn't really take
as much of a physical,
you know, tax on you as like say,
you know, a rugby or a cricket, right.
- No golf is fun as fuck.
I was like actually properly
into golf when I was younger.
Like to the point where I start getting
like proper golf lessons
and everything like that.
- I went to golf camp a
couple times. (laughing)
- [Garnt] You went to golf camp?
- Yeah.
And I was like 10 years old,
like during like summer holidays.
- [Connor] What's golf camp.
- It's literally just
like, think of you go
and like, you stay over
in like a golf club
for like a couple of weeks.
And every day you just get up
and you just learn to play golf.
- What?
- Yeah.
And I was, I think like 10
years old and it's like-
- [Connor] You like, forget how to do it.
- No, surprisingly, I
kind of remembered it.
- [Garnt] 'Cause you went to,
you went to a driving range.
- I went to a driving range
with Mark and Marline.
'Cause there was one like
kind of nearby my house.
And it was a really fucking fancy.
Like I knew this wasn't
like the, you know,
the downtown alley, like, you know,
fucking we're gonna build
this driving range here
because there's nothing
else around kind of thing.
Because it's like, you literally
got like a buggy service
from the car park to the
building, if you were far away.
- See, I feel like
there's always like levels
of like how into are you
into who like golf, right.
Because like I've never,
obviously I didn't come
the most privileged family.
Like the only golf clubs I've ever owned
were like a pair of
like a set of golf clubs
that I bought in a car boot sale,
like 50 bucks or something like that.
You know, so I always went to like,
or you know, the really
cheap driving rangers
and they're really cheaper golf courses
but those were still fun as fuck.
- The ones I went into back
in Australia were like,
still like obviously
made in like, you know,
it's like seventies and like eighties.
So it's still very old,
like you get like a,
there's just like this
machine that you just like,
press a button and you
put a basket under it.
And it just like shits
out a hundred golf balls
into a basket.
And then you kind of, you know,
one at a time you put it on the tee
and you like, whack it off.
This one we went to though,
I don't know if Japanese
driving ranges like this,
'cause this is the first time I went.
But like you walk in,
I'd never seen like this many
polo shirt in one building
and well like everyone
was like slicked hair,
like really like pristine
pants and everything.
Like clearly, like I was like,
oh, okay we're in like
a nicer driving range.
And they like made us like make these like
membership cards that you
didn't even have to pay for
you just like, they were like,
okay, the moment you're here,
you have to make a membership card.
I was like, okay.
So then you, and then
you fill this thing up,
like a credit card.
You put cash into it and then
you'd pay for the golf balls
using your membership card.
Because I was so used to the, you know,
the pressing the button,
then the balls sitting
out into basket thing.
So I was like, I was looking
for that machine, right.
I was like, okay, where is it?
It wasn't there.
It was literally just like,
it looked like a ATM and
you'd put the card in
and you were like, how
many balls would you like?
And I was like a hundred and it's like,
okay, go to this, you
know, go to this field.
It's like, where are the balls?
I was like, looking around, I was like,
where the fuck are the balls?
I was like, okay, whatever.
I'll just go to it.
There's a fucking, you get to it,
there's no tee on the green.
And I'm like, there's no tee,
there's no machine that
shits out the balls.
I was like, okay, what do I do.
And there's just like a
little like, you know,
and like golfing, not golfing,
bowling alleys, right.
You know, there's like the little tablet
that you have that shows the scores.
There was just like that,
but like a tiny one.
So I was like, and there's just one button
that just says start.
And I was like, okay, I press start,
the fucking tee with the
ball on top of it comes out
from under the green.
- Are you serious?
- [Joey] It just goes (mimicking machine)
- What the fuck?
- And I was like, oh.
And I whack it immediately
the moment I whack it,
the tee goes down another
ball appears in its place.
- [Garnt] Holy Fuck, I've been playing-
- And I was like, this
is the most fivehead,
why the fuck was I wasting my time?
- That sound amazing.
- I was playing golf like
a peasant this entire time.
- I was being an idiot looking around,
like where's the golf
ball shitting machine.
- That makes golf sound hella fun.
- It was so good.
And then you have like a counter
that shows how many balls you have left.
And if you say, for example, like,
you know, you pay for a hundred balls,
but you know, after a while,
after you swing a golf club
a hundred times, your arms and shoulders
start to get a little bit sore, right?
So you're like, oh, you know,
maybe I just wanna like call it a day
after 80 balls or whatever.
So you just press a stop,
the money comes back
into your membership card
and then you can just leave.
- Fucking now that-.
- How much is it like to do?
- It was 2000 Yens so
about $20 for 120 balls.
- That sounds fun as fuck.
- Which is, honestly not bad.
- 'Cause like I remember
playing golf as a kid
and it was like, it has the
image of being an odd man sport,
but it's like, I still
think golf is boring as fuck
to watch, right?
It's one of those sports where like-
- Just made people cry right.
(Joey laughing)
- It's one of those sports
where I'm just like,
I like golf. I get golf.
I don't understand anyone
here enjoying watching it.
- The only time I'll
ever sit down willingly
to watch golf is when
I find a YouTube video
on my recommend, which
is like top 10 miracles
during golf tournaments.
- I don't think playing golf is boomer.
I think watching golf is boomer. Okay.
I'm going to draw the line there.
I'm going to draw the line there. Okay.
- [Joey] That's fair. That's fair.
- But yeah, I mean like, I
remember I was actually like
super, super into golf.
I found it like super fun
because I wasn't really the
most athletic kid as a kid.
I mean, like, I was like
in the basketball team,
but I feel like I got put
into the basketball team
just because I was tall and
that was like the prerequisite,
but I didn't really enjoy so much playing
like really high intensity sports.
But then I just really enjoyed golf
cause it was more of like just a relaxing,
you just hone one skill
and then there was nothing more satisfying
than that moment where you
just hit the ball perfectly.
Right and you can tell
you hit the ball perfectly
because like sometimes you hit,
you hit the ball and
it slices or you know,
sometimes veers to the right
and then you could just,
you feel it in your hands,
cause there's like a
vibration in your hand
when you hit it a bit wrong.
But when you hit it and you
feel like it's like hitting air,
you know what I mean?
- It's like I'm hitting
nothing at all.
- Yeah, it's like you
hitting nothing at all.
- I've never played golf.
- You've never?
- Only mini golf.
- Okay, mini golf. I feel
mini golf has its own.
- We need to go play golf.
We need to go play golf.
- We should go to the driving
arrange near my house.
'Cause like that place was
actually like, I wanna go back.
I dead ass after that session,
I looked at Marky dead in the eyes
and I was like, where do
I go to buy a golf set?
I was legit this close to
just buying a golf set.
- 'Cause like I remember the one moment
that sold me on golf as a kid,
because I went to the driving range.
Driving range was just fun
because you just fucking hit a ball
and it doesn't matter,
it's just really
satisfying hitting a ball.
- I always wanted to.
- Yeah, but like
on like on like the actual golf course
is where you you have to like,
actually think about what you're doing.
You can't just like blindly hit a ball.
And I remember like I had
an instructor at the time.
And so like on the driving
range and in golf in general,
so if you don't know golf,
there's like a set of golf clubs
and that is numbered, right.
So the lower the number, the less-
- Less sharper the incline
is of the club, right?
- No, no, it's less incline.
- Oh less incline.
- Yeah, yeah.
So for example, like a two iron
goes almost straight, right?
So it's a lot harder to get the ball up
and give it like air time, right.
So for me, like my comfort,
my comfort zone was
like a nice seven nine.
- [Joey] I was about to say. (laughing)
- It's the seven nine.
- [Joey] It's the seven nine.
- The seven nine is like the comfort.
Because like on the driving range,
if you wanna feel like you can play golf,
you gotta have the seven nine, right?
Because you can get a decent amount of air
with a seven, nine,
like almost guaranteed.
- It's like a perfect 45 degrees.
- Yeah, but also like a decent
amount of distance as well.
So you could like, yeah, I
can whack a fucking ball.
I can whack a fucking ball.
So I remember I was on this golf course
with this instructor, right.
And so between me and the flag,
so basically the hole, there
was like this this hill, right.
And on the hill was
like a sand trap, right.
So I needed to get enough
air to get over the sand trap
and also onto like onto green, right.
- I feel like I know where this is going.
- And so in my mind, I'm
like, this is two shots,
this is two shots, right.
Because I need to get over the sand trap
and then another shot to get to the green.
So what happens?
I pull out my trusty comfort seven nine,
my good old trustee, seven nine, right.
And I'm about to hit it.
and my golf instructor goes, no,
you're not using that seven nine,
been using the seven nine
for the entire golf course.
And he picks out the three iron, right.
And he goes, use this.
And I go, I can't use that,
I can't get enough air.
I'm gonna hit the sand trap
and he goes, no, you can
do it I believe in you.
And I just like, what?
No, no, I can't do this, this is three,
this isn't even a five
iron, this is a three iron.
He goes, no, just do it,
just trust me, just do it.
And I remember like it was like,
you know being like when Neo
discovered that he was the one
in the Matrix fight,
because I remember hitting this ball
and I couldn't believe that it just like,
so this was the sand
trap, the ball went here.
It went just perfectly
enough over the sand trap.
And it perfectly landed on the green.
And I was just like, what is this feeling?
It's just, am I the chosen one?
What is this?
I know, like I like remember that moment
for the rest of my life,
because like, that was
the most satisfying shots
I've ever hit in golf.
And from that moment on,
I was like, even as a kid,
I was like, I can see
why people play golf now.
- The only thing that would've
topped that experience
is if your golf instructor in
the we sports voice was like,
nice shot.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Nice approach.
- So, I mean, it is a
very rewarding sports.
I mean, like all sports are.
- Yeah, because, so like when
I was at the driving range,
cause it was fucking I
don't know, five sixties,
at least minimum, since I
last went to a driving range,
I think I was in like high
school last time I went.
So obviously I was like, I knew, you know,
basically like how to
swing and everything,
but I was fucking slicing
that bitch like crazy
every single time and I'm like, man what,
why am I slicing it?
And just like, it got to the point
where I was like dead pan serious,
just like slowly, like just fucking doing
every single movement possible.
Being way too serious about
this shit and I was like,
and at one point I remember I was like.
I got it.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I swung.
- [Connor] Locked on.
- Yeah. I locked on, I was like,
this is the position right here.
I just have to nail this
and the moment I got it,
I think I nodded like it
was because again it's like,
as Garnt said, it's like,
when you hit that perfect
straight perfectly angled shot,
you just hear the
cleanest, like whack sound.
And nothing else.
But when you fuck up, you hear like a,
it's like a really like a fucked up sound.
- It's like the best
way I can describe it,
it's like, you know, when
you play some FPS games
and you get that headshot, right.
And like a lot of like
FPSs games have this like
really satisfying sound
when you get that head shot.
- [Joey] Ding sound.
- Like golf just has that IRL,
when you get that
satisfying, like perfectly,
like perfect headshot on that golf ball.
It's like designed to have
that satisfying sound.
- I wanna go.
It's just, how do you get into golf?
It's not like a thing that.
- Well, okay.
So I don't have a golf set or anything
Marky and Marilyn does,
but a lot of those places,
like in driving range and stuff like that,
they give you like rentals.
So the only ones they
gave me was a seven iron
cause of course.
(Garnt laughing)
- Is that just universal.
- It's just like, you've
never played just this.
- [Garnt] We'll start you
off with the seven iron.
- So all they gave me was
a driver and a seven iron.
- Like happy Gilmore's.
- You gotta do the runup.
- That's a good movie.
- Yeah.
Yeah and then you just like,
kind of just get a feel
for it after a while.
But it's, I think it's definitely
best to go with someone
who, you know, knows at
least the bare minimum.
- Knows how to swing a golf club.
- Yeah, my brother played a lot of golf.
Can't remember he played like,
I think he did like tournaments and stuff.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah.
But I never did.
I was always more into
like stuff that was like
way more active.
Running or just head butting walls.
- That was great, I mean
golf is like Monkey mode,
but like it's controlled monkey mode.
'Cause you just, you just gotta whack-
- That doesn't sound very monkey mode.
Stop tryna describe golf
in a way that I like,
it's not how it is.
- It's just whacking a ball. I mean.
- That's not monkey mode.
- No, just think of no,
no, instead of monkey mode.
- Just as monkey mode, you know
you swing like in the wild.
- Just think of instead
of it instead of an FPS
where you shoot someone in the head,
it's like an FBS, but like the bullet
is the end of the golf stick
and the ball is the head.
- That's such a shit analysis.
(Garnt laughing)
- That's all it is.
You get the perfect shot, boom satisfying.
- You don't even have to
sound me on golf, I wanna try.
- This episode is sponsored by Boksu.
- Do you guys smell that?
- Smell what Garnt?
- Oh the smell of fresh
spring air all around us.
- But God we're inside.
How can you smell the fresh spring air?
- Well, it's because I've got this
awesome Sakura season Boksu with me, Joey.
- How did I get that?
It's almost spring and you know
what that means, gentlemen.
It is the Sakura season here in Japan.
And Boksu got you lovely sunsets petals
covered with Sakura themed
sweets for this month.
- Do you know what
people in Japan do, Joey?
- What do they do?
- People in Japan celebrates Sakura season
by gathering under a tree for Hanami,
which is a flower viewing and
enjoying picnics together.
- And luckily gentlemen,
with this Sakura theme box,
you can have your very own Hanami at home.
Tell us Joey, what are you holding?
- Well, I'm holding some
Congoa sucker jelly.
- [Garnt And Connor] Oh!
- How beautiful this thing looks.
- So Garnt, what are you holding?
- This is a Sakura sweet cookie.
Look at this look.
- [Joey] That's so cute.
- [Connor] I know.
Did you know that Sakura season is Boksu's
most anticipated collection of the year
and if you've been waiting to try them out
now is the beast time.
As you can hear Garnt is
having the time and his life.
So use our code Trashtaste15.
And the link in the description now below
to save $15 off your first order.
- Go get yourself a piece
of Japan's freshest season
with the monthly Boksu.
- I'll have what he's having.
Back to the episode.
- Have you guys ever been to
any of the bating cages before?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I fucking love it.
- A lot harder than it looks.
- It is a lot harder than it looks.
- It's also a lot scarier than it looks.
Because even when you put it on like
the slowest mode or I
think a lot of machines
throw at like 80 kilometers
an hour and that's slow.
And you're like, oh yeah,
that doesn't sound too fast or anything.
But then you remember,
that's like the speed
that cars travel on some highways
and you're like, oh,
that that's pretty fast.
- I can hit a car with a baseball bat.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I can't hit a ball.
- At what cost.
- I mean, my arms will pretty fall off.
Those things are fucking hard.
I remember trying to do the 120.
And I out of like 20 shots,
I managed to hit one.
That wasn't very good.
I was just guessing.
- [Joey] It's getting into the speed.
- It's got a lot harder learning curve
than when you play in every mini game
on like any LOPG right?
'Cause like in like you play
on like Persona five whatever
you miss the first two shots.
- Baseball in Persona.
- Yeah. Yeah.
You can go to bating cage on Persona 5.
- Of course you can't.
- Of course.
You can do homework in Persona.
Why couldn't you like do
like go to batting games.
- That's how you up your charisma.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- How does it up your charisma?
- Because the more shots you get,
the more charismatic you're.
- You're so likable.
- It's like damn you
got 19 outta 20, seesh.
That's more charismatic as fuck.
- Weird way to define charisma.
- Yeah, but I remember
like you play on Persona
or any mini game or fucking
probably Yakza or something.
Yeah and then you missed
like the first two ball
and you're like, okay,
I got a feel for this.
You start getting them.
In real life you miss like the first 10
and you're like, I can't
even keep up with this.
Like my eyes still.
- In real life it's not even like,
you can't even attempt to
swing after the first few.
Like the first few is like seeing
how fast the ball actually goes
and by the time you realize
it, it's behind you.
You're like, oh, okay I'm
gonna be here for a while.
And then maybe around
like swing seven or eight,
you're like, I think I have
the courage to start swinging.
- I could just never swing faster enough.
My eyes were just were
way faster than my arms.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
That's what I learned.
I'm British. So we don't play baseball.
It's not a thing.
- Oh, I mean, you know,
Australia doesn't play baseball either.
- So like holding a
baseball bat was just weird
and trying to hit a baseball.
- Yeah, but we played cricket.
- We, I didn't play cricket.
- Well the Welsh and the British.
- I did not play any.
I've never played cricket.
- You didn't play cricket?
- I played in the infield one time,
I had to like catch
it, I never got to bat.
- But like everyone bats though.
- No, but like, cause we were,
when we were in school
we had like an hour, right?
So we never played it that often.
- But you never play
in like PE or whatever.
- Yeah we did. But I was
always in the infield.
I don't know why.
- But like this team swap over.
- Yeah, I know, but we never had time to,
we ran out of time.
So we never played it
often because you know,
you have to do like every sport.
So we didn't cricket often.
I was never good at the team
games. That's what I learned.
I'm really bad at team
games and we never did golf
cause that's like, how are you
gonna get kids to play golf?
It's not practical.
- I mean golf wasn't like
was never a PE thing.
It was more just like-
- [Joey] Like a extracurricular thing.
- But we did like, I don't
know, we did like everything.
- What was your favorite sport during PE?
- I always liked athletics
when we did that.
- Like running, long jump,
high jumps, stuff like that.
- Yeah, javelin. Javelin is
really fun, shot put was fun.
That's cause I was like a fucking animal.
- You seemed like a shot put.
- Yeah, you seem like
a shot put kinda guy.
Why that doesn't surprise me.
- Why does that doesn't surprise me.
- I as much as I've my God
damn hardest, I can like,
I cannot run long distances.
No matter how much I practice.
I'm sure there's some God tear runner
in the comments being like,
you just gotta, you
gotta past through man.
I gonna hit that wall,
you gotta keep going.
Never stop get that pump up.
- You gotta breathe through your nose.
- You know like I am a sprinter.
That's what I always was.
And like, whenever I, no matter
how many times I trained,
I just reject doing long distance.
But I wanted to sell God damn bad.
But yeah so I ended up
just doing sprinting
and like to me it's like
sprinting and like throwing
and long jump, it was all
kind of explosive energy.
- For me, high jump and long jump
was like the ones I excelled.
- I sucked high jump.
- Long jump for me was the best one
that I was in athletics as well.
- I was just really good at jumping.
I don't know.(laughing)
(indistinct murmuring)
- 'Cause my school was
really small so this a bunch,
so like I was the only
one who went to athletics
after school, like cause
we had a local track
that had been funded by the lottery.
So right next to where I lived,
there was these amazing facilities.
Like amazing track, nothing
like this anywhere else near me.
Like cause this is just like unheard of,
it was like an actual good track.
So I used to go there
and I was the only person
in my like year who did this.
So I was the only one who knew
how to throw like a javelin
knew to throw a shot put,
knew how to do long jump,
like the correct way.
- Did you do discs and stuff like that?
- I didn't do discus, so we were doing it
and every year we had
the sports day, right.
Did you have to do the track and field?
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah
- And you had like houses,
like Griffindoer and shit?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like your own version.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- I think I was in like the
house called scissors in well.
- Scissors.
- Scissors that wasn't rock or paper.
So it was like scissor or something.
And how did you decide,
who does the events,
how did you decide this?
- Basically it was just like picked.
It was like, would you
like to go to this event?
- If there was someone who was
obviously the best at event,
they would be like, well you're.
- Oh no, for us, it was just like,
you just put your hand up
and it's like, who wants to
do the hundred meter sprint?
And then everyone who wants
to puts their hands up
and then if you didn't wanna
do it, you didn't wanna.
- So if there was too many
people, how did they decide?
- Oh, everyone did it.
- Oh, there was no limit.
Well, I mean, to be
fair, my school as well
was also very, very small.
Like we only had like, you
know, 500 people in our school.
- How many people were in
your, your grade or year?
- Like 60.
- Okay, so yeah it's about, same for me.
So there was like only two
or three people were allowed
to do each event.
And for the first few years when I did it,
there was no limit on
how many you could do.
And so I was just like, I'll
just do like everything.
'Cause I loved sprinting,
I loved racing as well.
So I would do like, yeah, I'll do the 100,
200, 400 long jump, the triple
jump, javelin, shot put.
It was fun, it was good.
Because there was some people in my,
cause we only had like
groups of like 15 of us split
and there was like half
of them that were like,
I don't wanna do anything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was like, oh great.
- There always was.
- For me, you had like a maximum of four,
but like everyone did like
four or something like that.
- See, so then there
was one year where like
I did the 100, 200 and I'd
won all of the events but one.
And so I was like, oh, this is fun.
I won like six out of seven events.
And then the next year
they were like, no, no,
you can only do three now.
And I was like.
- [Joey] They snarfed you.
- I was like, why are snarfed me? Huh?
That's not fair.
But this is the thing, right.
Is that I'm sure if I
went to any other school
where people like knew how to do like
throw a Javelin correctly,
or like jump correctly.
'Cause like this when like long jump,
everyone was still doing the
jump where you like just jump,
not the one where you jump into a sit.
So it was really easy to like do better.
- Obviously.
- Yeah, I mean same with
like a high jump as well.
Everyone just like did like the, you know,
the standing scissor kick way.
But like I was doing the
full like fucking arch back.
Like Torpedo John.
- Right and then you're like,
oh my God, this guy's a God.
How the other kids can't compete.
You're like actually doing the
like professional technique.
- Exactly, I'm like, oh yeah
of course, you're only gonna
be able to jump like a menial,
you're fucking doing this.
- The is kick.
- Yeah, the is kick.
It's like yeah, of course.
- I couldn't do that
though. I was terrible.
I was really fun though.
I really liked it.
I mean, when you're winning,
of course you like it.
I thought that would make
me popular, didn't they?
- Yeah, well like during elementary
I was like dominating long jump in high.
(Connor laughing)
- [Connor] Turns up, yeah guys. I'm here.
- Definitely did not make me popular.
If anything, it just gave people more
cannon for right to be like, Ugh,
your name's Joey and you
you're good jumping things.
Just like a baby kangaroo.
I never fucking heard the end of that.
Christ
(Garnt laughing)
- I just felt like I just saw your soul,
just leave your eyes.
Like years of like torment
just came rushing back there.
(Garnt laughing)
- One time.
Very, very tense moment.
I just won the 100 meters
and immediately after
they were like, let's do the 200 meters.
They didn't think let's
space it out, right.
So I was actually naked.
And I was lining up for the 200 meters
and I really, really,
really wanted the win.
I wanted this more than like any,
I don't know why I was
so ultra competitive,
this is like the Olympics for me.
I was like, I need this.
I was so God nervous that
like, I was like, what is this?
I felt like a little drizzle
go down my leg, right.
I was so nervous that like,
for like a brief moment,
I peed myself.
(Joey laughing)
Like 0.1 seconds and I was like, stop.
- It's like a little beep.
- Yeah, it was like a
little beep and I was like,
that's never happened
before, what was that?
Fuck! Luckily I,
but you know, I didn't
give a that I peed myself.
My priority was like, no
one else saw that, right.
No one else saw that drizzle.
But luckily I was so sweaty
from the previous event,
still that nobody had
thought that pissed myself.
- Just like shake it off.
Just shake your leg.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Let's get back to it boys.
I went to it, the yeah I won.
But I really needed to piss after it.
(Garnt laughing)
My bladder it was so,
have you ever been that nervous,
your bladder is completely opened.
- Yeah. I've had that before.
- Is that happened?
- You trust me.
- I've never been in that.
- I didn't know that could
happen, until it happened.
- I've done the little
like before as well.
- I had that drink, I had that before,
like a really important
like piano competition.
(both laughing)
- It happens.
- But at least, but like the problem was
I had it a lot worse than you.
- [Connor] You probably
wear like nice pants.
- I was wearing a suit.
- Oh no.
- I was wearing shorts,
that shit just came out.
- And you were already sweaty right.
I was like in a well air conditioned room,
like long pants, like in a suit.
With like all these like
really properly dressed,
like Asian kids next to me.
I was just like, Ha! Oh fuck.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] Could you see
it? Could you see the pants?
- Oh, luckily not, but my God,
it was hard to use the pedal
while my leg was also a little bit wet.
I was like, oh God.
- How far did the stream get
down? Did it go all the way?
- Like almost to my knee.
- Oh my God.
- They missed this fucking
scene in your line April,
so was that been a fucking waiting.
- I love the chapter with
Connor said pisses himself.
(all laughing)
- When you're a kid, you get anxious.
- Exactly.
- I also used to try.
- I felt really bad for the
kid who had to follow after me.
- Oh my God.
'Cause I'm like I didn't check,
but I was like, I'm sorry
if the seat is a little wet.
- [Garnt] There's a wear patch.
- There wet patch on
that seat right there.
- I fucking nailed the competition though.
So worth it in the end, but.
- So did you win the 200 meters?
- I did. I did.
And I was also so competitive
to the point where I dunno
if I can do this now,
but when I was a kid,
when I was running and I thought like,
oh, I really need to stop.
I just wouldn't stop.
And I would always end up
throwing up when I stopped.
(Joey laughing)
- You are that kid.
You are the kid who just
threw up everywhere always.
- Because right to me, it was like,
I was like, no, I need to
win, like I have to win.
So like, if there was a,
like I'm at the last stretch
and I still got a little left in me
and I'm like, I can't stop
now, I need to throw up.
So one year, this is again.
So I was doing like six events
and I've won the 100, I've won the 200
and again, right after it,
what comes after the 200?
It's the 400.
'Cause it's kind of like the same thing.
You sprint at the end, you
kind of run fast at the start.
- Well why would they not split it up?
- It was a school.
- Cause in our school, they split it up.
- Yeah. I think they might have assumed
that different people would
be doing different events.
- I think they assume people
would do different things,
so like, I would get max
like two minutes break.
So I was doing the 400, right.
And I was already like, before
I even started this race,
I remember I was like (heavy breathing)
'cause I was already, still
naked from the other one.
And I was like, how the
am I gonna win this one?
And so I'm in this race, right.
I get to the 200 meter mark, right.
This is where you're like,
the on switch has to come on.
You have to start sprinting.
'Cause like I'm like kind
of like I'm in the middle,
I'm not really in, I got
a lot of ground to make up
'cause I was going a little too slow.
So I just start going crazy, man.
I get like to 50 meters and
I'm like, oh no. (screaming)
On the side, on the
side of the race track.
(all laughing)
Right, luckily it's a grass race track,
so that shit's just extra compost.
And luckily I was not in the middle.
I was, I was in the first lane.
So I'm like 50 meters, into this sprint,
I'm going all out and I just
have to, I just (screaming)
and it became a bit of laughing stock
for the rest of that day.
- That would've been amazing to see.
- I was literally just like
powering through like a machine
then just like had to just start vomiting.
It was awful.
(Garnt laughing)
'Cause I just didn't
know my limits as a kid.
I just didn't like, my willpower
was just beyond my body's
ability apparently.
But it happened all the time
during long distance as well,
I always threw up.
- Yeah like I sucked at long distance.
I think mostly because I have asthma.
So I could only do like
200 meters at most before
like my asthma would
like start to kick in.
- It was rough man. Long
distances are horrible.
- Yeah it is.
- 'Cause it was really muddy and freezing.
It was always during winter,
did you do it in winter?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You gotta be a real
masochist to enjoy long run,
like long running.
Like it's like, why would you,
especially people who do it
for like club activities and stuff.
It's like, what do you do after school?
I run. Why?
- So they make all the
kids do it when you did it.
- Yeah.
- No, no.
So like if kids, so basically
kids could opt in and out
at our school.
- Oh you could knocked out.
- Every kid needed to do an activity.
You know, you didn't have
to like a certain like,
you know, certain amount, but
you needed to do at least one.
- No, no, there were some
years where I was just like,
I don't wanna do anything today.
- What! Dude from my school, it was like,
on this day we're doing two kilometers.
You have do the two kilometers.
You have no choice.
- We had other events
for that kind of stuff
where like kids had.
- Are you talking about PE or sports day?
- PE.
- Okay.
No, if it's PE then yeah,
if we were doing activity.
- Sorry, Sorry.
- If it's PE everyone have to do it.
- You have to do the extra.
- Yeah, cause I remember that like,
they would like get
really angry at the kids
that were just like at walking
and they like shout at them and
be like, the fuck you doing?
- It's this like fucking army.
Like the SAS or whatever.
- Like, so because like
we had at our school,
we had like, I think like
four different sports days
or like four different.
- What? We had one.
- So we had the track.
- Winter Olympics in Australia.
- No, so we had like
a track and field day.
And then we also had like a,
what we called the swimming carnival,
which was we went to like
our local swimming pool
and we would doing like swimming events.
- We got one sports day in the year
and it was like,
- Just track and field.
- Every kid looked forward to it
because it was just basically
a day off from school
where you just do fun stuff.
- You could just sit on the grass.
- And then we had another sports day
where we did it on the beach.
So we did like, you know, like beach flags
and you know like races,
like thousand meter races
on the beach and stuff like
that and like surfing events
and stuff like that.
And that was just like
another day where like,
if kids didn't want to do it,
then kids didn't have to do it.
And then we had a fourth
one during the winter
and this was the worst one.
It was called, they don't have it anymore,
but it was called the Walkathon.
- Walkathon.
- Yeah, so it's think of
like a marathon, right.
Which is like 42 point
something kilometers.
It's that, but you can
walk it if you want.
So it was basically we
start from the school,
you'd walk 20 kilometers across
like seven or eight beaches.
'Cause that was like the area we lived in.
And then you'd turn around
and you'd walk all the
way back to the school.
And you'd have to do that during the day.
And I think they got rid of it
because cause I think some
of like the higher grade kids
were just like calling Ubers.
(all laughing)
- I would. Fuck that.
- Yeah, fuck that shit.
- Because like when you
reach like the halfway point,
you'd get like a sticker,
like put on your like wrist,
so like that's how you'd know
when you came back to the school
that you made it to the halfway point.
So it's like, that was
their like foolproof way
of making sure you did the whole thing.
- Speed runners be like, I found a clip.
- So what the senior kids would do
is that like they'd walk away from,
you know, they'd do a, maybe
like the first kilometer.
Yeah, they'd like walk into
a street, call an Uber,
get them to drive to like a kilometer away
from the halfway point
and they'd just like,
come out, being like,
oh, hey, I made it.
And then they'd do it again.
But I think they got rid of it
because like kids were cheating,
but it was also like a
charity event for the school.
So like you had to like, you
know, you had to pay like,
I think it was like a dollar
per student or whatever
for like this charity.
- [Connor] Paid to walk 42 km.
- Pay to walk 42 kilometers.
I mean, for some kids it was like,
oh fuck yeah we just have to walk today,
don't have to do class.
Hell yeah, I'll take that.
- Did you ever forget toll off in school
for stuff you did outside of school?
- Like as in like in the school grounds
or outside school grounds?
- Outside of school.
- Like what?
- So like the area where I went to school
was like really small.
And like I was like, I
don't know how old I was.
Must have been like 13, 14.
There was like a bunch
of like ruined castles
where I grew up.
And one time I was like
climbing the wall of this castle
and a teacher happened to
be walking in that park
during the day.
And she just saw me,
she didn't say anything,
but I was just climbing it,
I was having a great time.
Probably wasn't the safest thing.
It was quite high up.
And then I came into
school the next Monday.
'Cause it was on like a weekend.
I got blocked by the fucking teachers.
They told me off and I was
like, I was so confused,
I was like, this doesn't, is this allowed?
It was outside of school. What?
And they were telling me
off for climbing this wall
outside of school, not
even anywhere near school.
I was like teachers are snitch.
- I don't think we had anything like that
because like, the town on
that I grew up in was like,
it was small, but it was also quite wide.
So like, yeah.
I don't think I ever saw my
teachers outside of school.
- Yeah, I mean, I was in
like Hove and Brighton,
so I mean, that's like a city.
So I don't think people cared about.
Did you guys have, like,
did your schools have any
rivalries with like other schools?
- We were attached to another school.
- Yeah we had like a
sister school as well.
So the school I went
to was the boys school.
And then like at the bottom of the hill,
there was the girls
school, the sister school.
- We were like, our schools
were physically attached.
- But they were different schools?
- Yeah, so you could
walk to the other school
from our school.
- That just sounds like
a bad time. (laughing)
- That sounds like fights.
- Whether a lot fights happened?
- It was like the corridor,
like where like the walls
were like different colors,
like there was a weird line, right.
So that's where like, if shit went down,
it was always like, at this
like, it was like the DMZ,
in like North Korea.
(all laughing)
- It's like guard standing on the border.
- It was like shit went down.
So the reason why this weird like,
it sounds really bizarre, right.
So we were a Welsh speaking
school and we were really small.
And the one we were attached to
was a massive English speakings,
really fuck big English speaking school.
'Cause our school was
too small and like poor
to have our own like sports facilities.
So that school also
had this massive sports
like kind of complex attached to it.
Swimming, pool, tennis,
like massive sports halls,
Astro turf, massive fields,
tennis courts, everything , right.
They had everything like rugby pitches,
literally everything.
And so our school would basically share
the facilities with them.
So whenever we needed
to go to use the pool
or anything, we always
walked through this school
and went there.
So we could walk through their school,
but they couldn't walk through our school.
'Cause our school was on the edge.
- Why would the, like,
I'm just imagining like the
architect of that building,
just being like, this
is gonna be hilarious.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- They just wanted to make
a fight club between kids,
'cause of course kids are
gonna fucking fight eachother.
- And there was like that corridor
and there was two outside
gates that also connected
that were pretty big.
So whenever it was like
snow or anything as well,
that would turn into
like the fighting zone.
- I just remember a
story of like going back
to the teachers getting angry
outside of the school grounds.
Did you guys ever used
to do like PE activities
outside of school?
- Yeah, of course.
You'd go to other places.
- So like one of the ones
that we did quite often
was cause our school was
right next to a beach.
We did a lot of like ocean kayaking,
which was like really fun.
Like you just like two
or three boys at a time,
get on a Kayak.
- [Connor] That's dangerous.
- Yeah, it was very dangerous, but.
- Damn kayak, he got kayaking.
- I used to go kayaking.
- You guys got to go kayaking?
- Yeah and sailing.
- What the fuck.
What sailing?
- Yeah, we had sailing as well
- I had learned how to sail.
- I'm so jealous.
(Joey laughing)
- [Connor] I got good story for that.
- There was one moment in kayaking,
it's such a bad story, but there was like,
cause we were on Manley beach
and one of the beaches, cause
it's like a bay basically.
So surrounded by these cliffs
and there's a lot of
like really like pristine
like penthouses that are like
kind of overlooking the bay.
If you like kind of look up at the cliffs.
There was this one time,
we were just kayaking along the bay
and then one of the boys
was like, oye, check it out!
I'm like what?
And we look up and
there's just like a chick
standing like in a bikini,
just like looking down at us.
And you know, she was
a very attractive lady.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
And we were, you know, we were
in 11th grade, so we were 17,
18 stuff like that, yeah, so basically-
- I'm about to commit misogyny.
- So one of the kids was like.
- Sorry, I know what he's gonna say.
- So one of the boys just starts going.
tits out for the boys,
tits out for the boys and then-
- That sounds like most Australian.
- And then a couple and then
couple of the other boys
start joining along.
Tits out for the boys.
And then before you know it's like,
there's like 15 Kayaks,
like 30 boys in this bank.
Just going tits out for the
boys, tits out for the boys.
- Thunder.
- It was like a scene at a Mad Max.
It was fucking crazy and then
of course the girl flashes,
everyone goes, yeah!
- [Connor] Did she? What!
- [Garnt] Oh my god.
- And then teacher and of course
the teacher we had that day
was a female teacher.
She was like, what the
fuck are you boys doing?
And we just like bolt in our kayaks,
just like get away from the sea
and we got absolutely rinsed.
- That is the most teenage
Australian boys story ever.
- This what happens when you
study in boys only school.
- Yeah, this is what happens
in a boys only school.
- Tits!
I just remember that.
- How Joey didn't turn
into our slash nice guy.
(all laughing)
I dunno how that happened.
- I hate to admit I did join in the chant.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Just from peer pressure.
- [Connor] So he committed misogyny.
- I committed misogyny, I'm sorry.
- They didn't let you
do anything like that.
- No, I mean, like I wouldn't
trust a kid out in the sea.
I'm surprised how other people did.
- We got to go to areas in Wales
that were like kind of
a like camps for like
three, four days.
And they were basically
like, they would be like,
listen boys, we can do
kayaking or you can do sailing.
The problem is you only got six sailboats
and we've got, everyone else
can do kayaking, like 30 kids.
And I was like, oh shit,
even though I didn't really like sailing,
I didn't know anything about it.
I was like, well, that's
the one that has less,
I wanna do that.
So I put my hand up to do it
and somehow I got chosen to do it.
I did sailing, I fucking
loved it, it was amazing.
But they gave us those like,
you know, boat plastic, like
really cheap boat plastic,
the one where you like knock
it and it sounds hollow.
It's really coarse as well.
It basically like a boat
that was a shell of plastic
with a, like what's it
called, is it a hole?
What's the thing that goes to the bottom.
With the rudder.
- Sail.
(Joey laughing)
- Just in the bottom.
- I have no idea.
- I don't remember.
- I forgot what it's called.
So you just have this slab of plastic
that you put in to allow
you to sail basically.
And then when we learned
how to sail and it was great
and yeah, it was really good, cause like-
- [Staff] Talking about the mast.
- The mast. No, no, no, no, no.
- I've never sailed before in my life so.
- This mast was at the front
and then it was one way you turn it
and then they in the bottom
underneath the water,
you slide in a thing.
Not the rudder.
- [Staff] Not the rudder.
- [Joey] I dunno.
- It's a sailboat.
So you didn't do the direction with the,
you did the direction
with the sail, not the-
- Like you'd pull on the
sail and stuff like that.
- You pull on the sail,
you lean like, it was really cool.
'Cause like you been
doing that badass shit,
like you'd be leaning half the
boat would be out the water
onto the sail, it was so fucking good.
- Horizontal on waters.
- Just drifting.
- [Staff] Is it the Keel?
- [Connor] Maybe I don't know.
Either way, so, and then you would like,
you would be taught like,
okay, let's say you flip your boat.
Here's how you jump out the boat,
jump on the piece of
plastic outside the boat,
push it down, jump back in
the boat and get it back in.
So fucking cool, I loved it so much,
I got really good at it.
And then the head guy
was like, you know what,
every year or so the kid who
gets really good at sailing
and I let him try the real boat
and I'm like, oh shit really?
And then, so he like out of this like
really gross looking shed in the water.
It was one of those sheds that was like
kinda there's no flow,
it's just for the boat.
He pulls out this massive
Catamaran, massive.
I've been in this like one person boat
this thing could easily fit like four,
to six people on it, right.
He's like, go take it out for a spin.
And I'm like this looks fucking scary.
- What did he say it like the
rich uncle, loans Ferrari.
Let's take it out for a spin boy.
- Felt like the sword in the stone test.
Let's see if you can handle this one.
(Garnt laughing)
So I start taking this thing out.
It's going well, I'm managing it.
It's a lot harder, you have to run,
you have to like get across way more,
a lot more really full body.
'Cause you've gotta really
like get underneath,
you really gotta like throw
yourself around on this thing
to steer it, it's going
well, it's going well.
Suddenly we get a big gust of wind
and I'm trying my God
damn best to save this.
I'm trying my best. I get to the side.
I'm tryna unleash the mass
so that we can get some like,
we can get the boat back down.
Unfortunately the boat just keeps going.
It keeps going and then it doesn't,
it gets sideways completely.
From this point now
this boat is too heavy.
Unlike the other boat where my body weight
could shift it back, like my
body weight can't do shit.
And it is literally like the
sinking boat, like Titanic.
It is just like I'm sitting
on the top of the boat,
like at the top of the thing,
just slowly going down.
Until it gets about the halfway point
where it won't sink anymore, luckily.
So I'm just sitting there
and then he comes over disappointingly
in like the speed boat
and he's like, I see.
He's like-
- You aren't the chosen one.
- You are not the one.
- He's like, I see.
He's like, well at least help me
tie the rope around this
part and I took it back over
and then he got on the
boat and he was like,
I'll show you how to drive it.
And I was like,
(Garnt laughing)
I let him down. I let him down.
He sailed it back and then
I was like a disappointment
and I was never allowed to try it again.
There was a fucking, I felt like that was
a look in hindsight, I
feel that was ridiculous.
- I feel like that was a big step up.
- It was alone as well with the catamaran
you can normally have
like two people on it.
It's the big one with the big net,
you know what it is
right, it's ridiculous.
It wasn't like a full sized massive one,
it was like a smaller version,
but still, it was like-
- I'm so jealous. I never
got to do that in my school.
And we live in Brighton.
- You live in Brighton.
- Not even kayaking?
- It was in a lake and a
river, so it's a lot easier.
It was a really big lake, but you wouldn't
wanna do that in the ocean.
- That's dangerous.
- You get swept fucking away.
In this lake you were just
happy for me ask about it.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't
think there was any
like big lakes near us,
so we didn't really do any water sports.
I think the most we did was just,
we had like a swimming
pool, a local swimming pool.
- What do you mean
there's lakes everywhere.
- I know, I mean, we're not,
like how far did you need to
drive to get to this lake?
- Two, three hours.
- You drive two, three
hours just for this one.
- That's like the entirety of Wales.
- That's like a fucking
school trip for us.
- It was, it was.
It was like a three day
weekend school trip.
- Oh, you made it sound
like it was one afternoon.
- You made it sound like, oh yeah,
for this one lesson in PE.
- No I said three or four
days, three or four days.
- No, because like the
kayaking thing for us
was just like down the road.
- Oh no, no, no.
It's like, so there's like areas in the,
I'm pretty sure it's funded
by the Welsh government.
But it's like, basically
every Welsh school
gets like a weekend there.
- Right.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
- So everyone gets to have turns.
So these like, they're
like really fucked up.
- [Joey] That makes more sense.
- So like, yeah, there's like a, you know,
it's kinda like a thing you go, it's like,
hey, try a bunch of different
sports, try kayaking,
try canoeing, try sailing,
wall climbing, like everything.
Just try to do everything,
suite what you like.
And so it was really fun
and I'm glad got to do it.
I wish I kept up with sailing.
But unfortunately sailing
is a very luxury sport
to be able to do this.
So not like, oh yeah,
you can just go sailing.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Unfortunately, it sucks really.
'Cause I feel like there's
so many sports out there
that I could have fell in love with,
but the financial instability.
- The absolute economical stayed.
- That like every sport
ever for everyone, right.
- I mean, that's was like me
and skiing and snowboarding.
That's why I never was
able to get into it.
'Cause my family unfortunately
could never afford
to you going on a skiing
or snowboarding trip.
- It's either not enough money,
not enough space or both.
- Yes.
- Well I'd love to,
I've been skiing and snowboarding
like the majority of my life
and I would love to earn
a snowboard or skis,
but it is an absolute nightmare
to deal with transporting
it and taking it everywhere.
And I also, it's pretty expensive.
- [Joey] It is expensive. Yeah.
- I know that you can ship
it from hotel to like-
- God you sound like you had
such like fun school trips.
You went to like America
for a school trip.
- That's fucking crazy to me.
- Well that was insane,
that was like the first
year they did that.
And that was really expensive as well.
I remember I had to like beg
my parents and they were like.
- 'Cause our school wasn't that rich.
Like I think the richest
thing that our school did
for the rugby team,
cause we like excelled
in sports at our school
was like the senior rugby team was allowed
to go to like play rugby in Europe.
- [Garnt And Connor] Oh wow.
- Yeah, but like that was only like
the select like maybe like,
you know, top 20 people who
were like good at rugby.
- I can't even remember what
we did for our school trips.
- The rest of the time
we just went to like the local water silo.
- Yeah, yeah. Something boring.
- I dunno if this is just cause like
it's a really small place,
but I imagine that when you're in a city
it probably feels like less inclined
to get you out of the city.
Whereas when you're in the
countryside, there's nothing.
So I feel like they had way more pressure
to try and get you to do something.
Especially cause you know,
in at least sport in Wales,
like sports is like a massive deal.
It's a very important
part of like the culture
and doing sports as seen as a very, very
like you have to do it.
Doesn't matter what you do just do sports,
like it seems do what you gotta do.
So, you know, there was
a really big incentive
for them to make us go and do sports
and go on sports trips and
do all this kind stuff.
- I think the farthest we
ever went in a school trip
or anything was like
during like school camps.
But that we did every year
and that was like maybe like,
you know four, five hours away.
Which in the grand scheme of
Australia is not far at all.
But like, yeah, I don't remember
like going on like school excursions
going further than like an hour away.
- Yeah, I mean, the furthest I ever went
for a school trip was like France.
'Cause every school trip
goes to France for like it's-
- Well you're in Brighton
it's fucking easy.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- At least you fucking Europeans
got to go to other countries
that was not in for us.
- Other countries are like,
don't exist, Australia.
- It's like, oh what's
the closest country,
Papa on Y Guinea. How far away is that?
Like a three hour plane
ride, its like your cool.
- Your own country is like far
away from your own country.
- We couldn't even, even get
to go to the other states.
Like that's too far.
God forbid we're gonna be on a
plane for an hour and a half.
No, of course not.
- You probably had better
school facilities though,
than we had.
We get to go on a trip and they were like,
just forget about the fact
that you have to share a chair.
(all laughing)
- I mean, yeah.
No, I mean, even then
it was like, you know,
like school camp, for
example, it was like,
yeah, I guess, you know,
everyone got their own seat
on the bus or whatever,
but like that was the most we got.
- Got your own scene on the bus.(laughing)
What privilege.
- Well, okay.
What were your, I didn't get school meals,
but like were your school meals good?
What did you get?
- We didn't get school meals.
- [Connor] There was no cafeteria?
- There was a cafeteria.
- What did they serve at the cafeteria?
- Most like luxury thing
ever was this was fucking,
it was two chicken
tenders in a bread roll.
(Joey and Connor laughing)
- That shit cost $4.50.
- What?
- To me you knew the kids
who were eating goods
were who were the kids that could afford
a ham and cheese panini.
- Your school had ham and cheese panini?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You got fucking panini dude?
- Bro they gave you more than
they just called it bread.
That was all we, everything was bread.
- For us it was literally just two fucking
microwave chicken tenders in a hotdog roll
and then if you wanted
ketchup or mayonnaise,
it was available for
you for like 20 cents.
- Oh my God.
- But even then it was like,
cause, so like I never bought anything
at our cafeteria just because I was like,
I'm not fucking paying 50
for Chicken tender roll.
Like that's ridiculous.
- This is where child Connor
really learned inflation.
Like this is where it
really came to hit me.
'Cause I remember I used to have,
I was always given the
same amount of money
from like the young age
to spend at the cafeteria.
And I remember like when
I started high school,
I could get any of the meals.
They weren't amazing meals,
by the end I literally
couldn't buy any of the meals
unless I like had half
a meal the day before
and then saved and then and then yeah.
- Why did you not renegotiate
with your parents,
like mom, dad.
- Their mindset was like,
well your brother managed completely fine
throughout high school with this much.
So what's you're problem?
- Well, yeah, because I
think in my household,
like I got allowance for
doing chores like per month.
And you know, it was like maybe like,
you know, 20 bucks max per month, right.
Which, you know, to a 10
year old is a lot of money.
But at the same time when
your school at age 10
gave you fucking meat
pies for like a dollar 50.
You know, there's like
squeezy ketchup packets.
Those were 20 cents and I was like,
dog, I'm not paying 20 cents.
I'm not paying a literal
100th of my monthly allowance
for a little fucking squirt of ketchup.
Like I'm not doing that.
- You guys didn't have packed lunches.
I had to have packed lunches
for most of the days.
- So like most of my days for me as well
was like packed lunches, right.
Because my mum was like, I'm
not giving you fucking money.
all that expensive.
- Cause for me like,
my allowance would like
last the entire week.
And then I'd treat myself to
the ham and cheese panini.
That was like the Friday
meal that was like.
- See you did it the smart way.
I was like, you know what,
I could buy that chicken tender roll,
but I could also buy
this Yugio booster pack.
- Okay, okay.
(all laughing)
- I was gonna say,
here's what I did, right.
I would get, so I'd get
two pounds a day, right.
Which was like, I could buy one meal
if I waited like a day and
like had something small.
And so I was like, but I actually
want video games instead.
So I would go into the town,
which is like a 20 minute walk.
I would go to the, it's called
home bargains in the UK,
it's like a pound land or whatever.
I would buy a family bag of crisps,
like 12 pack for a pound.
And I would just eat that the whole week.
This is awful, this is pretty wild.
- This the most British
thing I've ever heard.
- You were rationing on chips.
- So you were just on
a crisp diet as a kid.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I was.
Because right, a video game
back then was 30 pounds.
So if I did this for a whole
month, I got a new game.
Sure my mom was wondering
where the I got this game from,
but she didn't even
know that I was getting,
I was eating Chris.
It was probably an awful
thing to do in my body,
but I didn't care I was like 15.
I wanted the video game.
- You see, you had so
much more of a stronger
willpower than me because
like I could not save money
for that long.
- I couldn't.
I had the object in mind.
I was like, I want the new halo game.
I'm not eating.
- No dude in my head I was like,
every time I went to
like a electronic store
and I was like, oh, the
new Mario Party is out.
How much does it cost? $80.
- [Garnt And Connor] Oh!
- I'm like, okay,
I could save up four
months worth of allowance
to get it, but my birthday
is also in seven months time.
So maybe I could just like hint at it now
and then just wait seven months for me
to actually get the game.
Which is what I did.
- Yeah cause for me, like when
I wanted to buy a video game,
like I grew up in like,
when I was in school,
it was like the N 64 SNES era.
And like games back then
was like 60 pounds a game.
For like a cartridge game.
- Wait, was it really?
- Yeah, yeah, it was.
- Was it like halved?
- Huh?
- It like halved.
- Yeah, like I remember when
like games start coming out
on discs, I'm just like, why
is it so much cheaper now?
What the hell and the graphics are better,
this is what kind of hacks they put in.
- PS2 was like me producing those things.
That makes sense.
- Yeah, so like back in those days,
like there was no fucking way I can afford
like a cartridge game.
Like the only times I
was getting new games
was like Christmas and birthday.
Those were the two times of
the year where I got games
and like, I was praying
that I could, like,
I was praying that my parents bought
like the right games every time man.
- Yeah. I was like, mother I
have waited an entire year.
If I don't get at least three
games, I am going to rage.
- When I turned like 16, they were like,
we want you to have a bit of an allowance
so that you can learn
how to manage your money.
And I was like, oh thanks.
And I was just thinking like,
I've got a lot saved already though.
(all laughing)
I was like, this is just
adding to the wealth.
This is how I've become Jeff Bezos.
- I think my parents thought the same way,
but only after they found
out that I got rejected
from my McDonald's job.
So they were like, there's no saving you,
we'll up your allowance.
so you don't end up being a bum.
- The more I think about
it, the more I was like,
yeah I dunno if I was always gonna be
that kind of way with money.
I dunno, I wonder is it like I do.
I guess you have to teach
your kids you how to learn,
how to manage money.
Sometimes I see videos, people are like
nobody taught me how to manage money.
I just spent it all when
I was like 20 and stuff.
And I'm like, oh.
- You do this. (laughing)
- By the way very, very,
very British thing.
What Chrisp I was eating by the way.
- Walkers. No.
- That's too expensive.
- Quavers.
- No think cheap.
- Think cheap.
- Don't look at me, man.
- You don't know.
This is from very British
audiences right now.
- I dunno.
- I just gonna hit you
like a wave, discos.
- Oh my fucking God! Okay, okay.
I completely forgot
that they even existed.
I haven't had discos since like my.
- You like 12.
- Yeah, I was like, did
I reach double digits
for the last time I had disco?
Like I can't fucking remember.
- Like the cheap shoot chips.
- They were like weirdly good.
But there was probably so
much like MSG and shit.
They were really tasty.
But they were weirdly like super cheap,
like compared to all other chips,
but they taste really fucking good.
- Chris review.
This episode is sponsored by Book Walker.
- What's up my beautiful
Book lover brethren
we're Trash Taste.
And we are here to introduce
to you Book Walker.
- What's that?
- Oh, you know, just one of
the most popular ebook stores
for English manga and
light novels out there.
- On the app you can read official eBooks
directly from the publishers themselves,
meaning you don't only just
get the newest releases
from manga and light novels,
but by doing so you also support
the original authors as well.
- Oh my God.
Anything new to the platform,
you should check out
their limited time deal,
where you can get up to 50% coin back
on the total amount from
your initial purchase.
- Wait that's a huge bargain.
You mean I can buy all 34 volumes
of Attack on Titan and
then I get back 17 volume
worth of coins to spend on other eBooks.
That can't be right.
- No way, no way.
- You are exactly right.
- What?
- And if that doesn't
sound enticing enough,
for new users you can use our coupon code
trash taste at checkout.
You can save $5 on your first purchase.
- So, what are you waiting for?
Sign up to Book Walker for free today
and enjoy some of their
generous discount promotions,
coin back campaigns and digital
bonus items for free today.
- So check out that service
by clicking that link
in the description down below,
thank you to Book Walker.
And back to the episode.
- I've always had like,
because I don't know if it was
just my school in Australia,
but like, you know,
when watch like American
like high school movies.
And that had like the
cafeteria, like the cafeteria.
Where there was like the lunch lady
and there was like, this was
like the serving of the day,
you know, kind of shit like.
I dunno why, did you
look at that and go like,
I wish I had that in my school.
- I think Americans wish they
had that in their schools.
- I mean like, cause I remember like
watching American high school movies,
and I'm like damn I wish my
high school was this cool.
- Like every Simpsons episode I watched
and like Bart was in the cafeteria,
I was like, man that looks cool.
What, does every American
school have that.
Behold I know not every
American school has that.
- I was just shocked
that everyone had cars.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
That's what blue meal.
- Yeah, there's like 15
year old kid and it's like,
it was like, yeah, I'll
pick you up tonight.
I was like, do you mean your parents
are gonna pick you up tonight? Or.
- I dunno what was going
on in the two thousands.
But like every single
thing it wasn't about like,
if you had a car, it was
like which car you had.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- What, you all have cars?
- It's like yeah oh, sorry
I'm gonna go pick you up.
- When did you guys first
like learn to drive then,
Did you learn how, how
to drive like immediately
when you could or did you.
- Yeah, like when I.
- Complicated story.
- Oh, for me it was like
the moment you hit 16.
- What's complicated about it?
- How did this be complicated?
- So I started learning how to drive
when I was 17, which when
you could do in the UK.
But what sucks is that because
my birthday was in July,
which is the end of the school year.
People who started in
September had already like
way past got their cars and were driving.
- Wait your school year ends in July.
- [Connor] Oh sorry ends
in September. Sorry.
- September?
- No starts in September.
- Sorry starts in September
ends in like August.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Really?
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- I don't know if we're talking about.
- [Connor] Wait, when does yours?
- It's January.
- Your school year starts in January?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What?
- It ends in December, starts in January.
- Whoa. Okay.
So wait, how do summer
holidays work for you then?
- Summer holidays is December.
- But then when do you
get Christmas holidays?
- Actually it technically
starts in February.
So we end school middle of December.
And then you celebrate Christmas
and holidays during holidays.
And then all of January
is summer holidays.
And then you come back in February.
- So how long do you get off them?
- During summer holidays?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like depends on the school,
but like usually like a month and a half.
- Oh, cause we get like
nearly three months.
'Cause it's pretty much
the first half of August
is when it ends, right.
- Yeah, well we talking university
or were we talking like secondary school?
- Secondary both are the same right-ish.
- Yeah, for us it was all the same.
- No, no, no in university,
I remember in university you get like
fucking three months off.
And those were like,
that was like before that
like school holidays for me were always,
the summer holiday was six weeks.
It was always six weeks.
Winter holidays was two weeks
and then we'd have like half terms
where you'd get like, where
you'd get like one week off,
like halfway through the term.
- Spring and autumn holiday.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So all together we got like,
we must got like about two
around two months of holiday
that was spread out.
And then like university
here and I remember thinking,
yo, what the fuck, we get
three months off for summer,
why am I even going to
education anymore man.
- The first time I experienced
the first like summer holidays in uni,
I was like, well see you
at university never again.
(all laughing)
- I remember when summer
holidays started in university,
I'm just like, wow, I'm just
not gonna go back to uni.
That's three months, right?
That's like, you know
what you can't imagine
the end of summer holiday.
- But yeah so the point was that
basically kids who were born in September.
Sorry fuck am I saying.
Kids who had their
birthday like in my year
who were like really close
to the start of the year.
Basically got to have their
license and already had it
and cool as shit.
- And you were right at the end.
- So they were in my year.
'Cause it didn't matter
if you the year above.
'Cause you weren't friends, right.
Even if I was closer in age technically.
So like the people who got it first
were like the coolest ones.
'Cause everyone was like,
oh can we gimme a lift now?
Oh, I'll drive you there. It's like fuck.
- Wait, so it's like for, in the UK,
you guys have like different stages
in your driving license, right?
Like you have like learner.
- Yeah like provisional,
- Provisional stuff like that.
So when you're on your first level,
like when you first start.
- There's two levels.
You have, or you're learning.
- Okay, so when you are learning,
can you just like drive by yourself?
- [Garnt And Connor] No.
- Okay.
- There needs to be
someone who supervises you.
- Supervises you and has,
how many years of experience?
So X amount of years driving
and you can't go on like the highways.
- Yeah.
- So like it's only
until your provisionals
that you can drive by yourself, right?
- Yeah, but the problem is that normally
not that you can't find someone
it's that you can't get a car.
'Cause you need to be insured.
And that was what the hard part was.
'Cause insurance for like a
17 year old is ridiculous.
- [Joey] You need to be insured.
- Yeah, you need to be insured.
- No, I could just use my mom's car.
- [Connor] You might have
had family insurance.
- Oh, maybe, I don't know.
- But like, if you are
under family insurance,
your price gets like tripled.
- If you have a 17 year
old on your license.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It's insane.
Like the reason why it was just like
no one owned a car except for a few people
was cause the insurance cost
was like triple of quadruple the car.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- The car was nothing.
Like my mate got a car for like
a hundred quid of some guy,
the insurance was like a thousand plus.
So it was like-
- Jesus.
- It was more cost for the
insurance than the car itself.
- But lessons were expensive as well.
I did lessons, my brother
had already passed
and you know, so it was my turn.
I was doing it and it was going well.
And then every now and then
the guy would just kind of
call me up, 'cause I was
learning through a guy.
That was how you mainly learn in,
at least the countryside in the UK.
And he was kinda flaky.
He would kind of like, he
wouldn't show up sometimes
and then sometimes he would just stop
and then I'm about, I
wanna say two thirds away
from getting my test and he just calls up
and he is like, oh yeah,
by the way I've quit,
I'm just not doing anymore.
I'm not doing, I'm sorry
that I don't wanna do
instructing people, cause
the costs on the car
are too much and stuff.
And I was like, oh, okay.
All right well, so I thought,
oh it can't be too hard
to find another one.
My mom just could not
find another instructor.
'Cause they're all booked up.
'Cause there's not many in my area.
- This is during your
learning stage, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Normally like they get
booked up pretty quickly
'cause there's not that many,
cause it's not very profitable.
It's really like, doesn't make much money
and it's a lot of work
and it's a lot of upkeep
on the car as well.
So he did that and then I
couldn't find one for like,
I wanna say right up
until like three months
before I was leaving for university.
So I had to get back into it.
It'd been like a six, seven months.
'Cause I couldn't find any one.
Started doing it again and I
was kind of getting okay at it
and I was maybe like, I don't know.
I wanna say like 10
lessons off doing the test.
I'd go to university and
then I just didn't do it.
- Yeah of course.
- 'Cause like I was busy having fun.
- 'Cause like, and you don't
need a car at university.
- Definitely.
- You know, I didn't have my license
and then it became something
that I was kind of like,
okay, don't really want
to do this anymore,
cause it's kind of in the way,
it's really pain in the ass
and I have to start from zero again,
and if I did do it, I thought,
oh I'll do one of those
like, cause you can do
like weak intensive course.
Where you just drive for
like eight hours a day.
And then you do your test
and hopefully you pass.
Statistically they're
like the worst drivers.
But you know-
- 'Cause you're basically
speed running, driving.
- So, you know, I'd gone through
all the uni, never did it.
And this point, like in the
UK you have to two things,
a theory test and a practical test.
Theory's really easy but
it only lasts two years
after you've done it.
So mine had expired. So I
had to go and do it again.
So I was in London and I
was like, oh fuck okay,
I'll go and get it, I'm
gonna actually learn a drive.
And then I booked one of these courses
that was like really expensive.
For like five days.
And their like promise
was you will guaranteed
get your license by day five.
- And anyone who says guaranteed,
guaranteed to get a license
that's sus as fuck man.
- So I started driving
and I had this guy and who's Welsh,
well, I was like, oh great he's Welsh,
should be really nice.
- [Joey] I can bribe him.
(all laughing)
- Well, he wasn't my,
he wasn't testing me,
but I was using his car
and you're also allowed
to use that person's car
for the test and stuff.
You know, it was really good.
He was nice, start you know,
he was like, oh you Welsh,
good, good I like Welsh people.
We're both in London, so it was
kind of like, oh nice, nice.
He was really weird.
He would also take any opportunity
to insult women drivers.
He was really weird.
- I'm about to commit misogyny.
- Every car just pass,
tits out for the boys.
(all laughing)
- Anything would happen
and he would be like,
fucking woman driving it,
fucking woman driving.
I was like, it's a guy.
And he was like (mumbling)
I was like, well fine.
It's really uncomfortable
at times you see things.
And also he would sometimes, you know,
cause you were in the car for
like six hours, seven hours.
You know, you'd talk
about life in and stuff.
He'd bring up some things and
he'd bring up some of his,
his views on the world.
That you'd be like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
(mumbling) Terrible
situation can't stand it.
We're parking by the way.
How long, where are we going?
- My dad as well, kind of
has like that weird like,
he creates this like
stereotypes outta nowhere
when it comes to like driving.
It's so weird.
Now that I think about it,
I'm like every time I
remember there were moments
where like my dad would be driving,
my dad will say he doesn't have road rage.
He absolutely have road rage.
I don't care what he says
because every time I remember,
like every time he'd be on the road
and there'd just be like someone
who's like taking him off
or whatever reason, he'd
be like, oh fucking move
and then he'd, you
know, get into the lane,
looking dead and like do
the Luigi death stare.
And then he'd be like,
oh, it's Volvo driver.
(all laughing)
- All dads do.
- I don't think every
Volvo driver is necessarily
a bad driver.
- Like BMW drivers, like
a massive dickheads.
- I'm like, well what is
your personal vinderian
against Volvo.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember like the,
one of the biggest stereotypes was like,
Asians are like bad drivers, right?
And like, I don't think
necessarily Asians are bad drivers.
I think Asians just drive by
the rules of their own country.
Which is just like a fucking free for all.
'Cause like I remember when
I first learned how to drive,
I didn't actually first
learn how to drive in the UK.
So I believe like.
- Oh my God, Garnt turns up
in the UK like crazy taxi.
- So what happened is, so I
was like turning 17 that year.
So I could learn how to drive in the UK,
but I believe in Thailand,
like you can like start
learning from like 16.
I'm not sure if that's,
I'm not sure the exact age,
but I remember I could legally get lessons
to learn how to drive.
So I was just like, right,
why don't I get head start
on learning how to drive
before I start to drive in the UK.
So I start learning to drive
in Thailand in Bangkok.
Right.
- God.
- It's like the Dark Souls
of driving. (laughing)
- It's like the Dark Souls of driving.
So like I take a few lessons
there and I get, you know,
get pretty confident
in driving, in Bangkok
with Thailand rules, right.
So you know, I can
competently handle the car
and definitely competently handle traffic
you know what I mean.
And so I remember I go back to UK
and I turn 17 and I sign
up for my first lesson.
And then, so the instructor turns up
and you know, we just
have a casual chat before,
before we start driving.
And then he asked me, have
you had like any experiences
or did you like use your
provision license or whatever?
And I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah,
I've actually, like learned
how to drive in Thailand.
Like I said this like with confidence,
like I know how to drive a car.
- You'd be breaking it.
- Yeah. I know how to drive a car.
I've started to learn
how to drive in Thailand.
You know, I've pretty
confident on Bangkok roads.
- He's gonna be could you repeat that?
- And so, you know, so I'm
pretty confident about it.
So he was like, okay, okay.
So let's get this first
lesson started then.
And so immediately I just
drive off and he goes stop,
you've immediately failed,
because I didn't check my mirrors.
- I know they do this to be like,
they just want you to do it, I understand.
But like that the guy had
right when I was doing this,
it's like, he couldn't just
say you did something wrong.
He had to be this whole
ordeal where he was like,
that was a really good turn, for a bitch.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
It was like,
nothing could be every
single thing had to be
packaged with an insult.
It was like, that was really
good on the roundabout
if you wanted to kill someone.
- If you're a woman.
(all laughing)
Oh, you didn't check your
mirrors, like a woman.
He would do this all the time.
It was so infuriating.
'Cause I was just trying to get good.
And every single time I'd
be like, how was this?
He's like, yeah, that was great,
if you wanna kill someone Connor.
And I was like, just tell me how it was.
- At least for you, it was just like,
not checking your mirrors.
Like my uncle failed
his first driving test
because he was like, all
right get in the car,
check all the mirrors, all
right, let's drive off.
It's like, stop you've immediately failed.
You drove out the exit.
(all laughing)
- No, no.
- It's like, oh all right.
So he literally got in the
car, didn't even make it
out of the driveway and he was like,
you've instantly failed
come back tomorrow.
- I mean you do it, don't they?
- Yeah because like,
I remember when I learned
how to drive in England,
I basically had to relearn driving
from like what I was taught in Thailand.
'Cause in Thailand, they
teach you like awareness
and control, like vehicle control.
But like in the UK, it's all
about here's the procedure,
Check mirror A, check mirror B.
- [Joey] Check your blind spots.
- Yeah, yeah. Check your blind spots.
I get it, but like in Thailand,
it's just like you must learn
to become super sane ultra instincts.
This is how you drive.
- It's the best way to
take a hit from a car.
If someone hits you on
the head, how you curl up.
- This how you take the least casually.
(all laughing)
- Inflict, maximum damage on my ass hole.
So, I did this five day thing right.
Where we were going
through and I had this guy
and he was kind of a slog and I remember,
I really didn't like doing it.
'Cause the guy was like
not, he was not fun.
And also driving in London sucks.
It's like going slow simulator
and stopping, waiting,
giving way to people.
Like just, it's not like driving
outside of the London like at all.
It's completely different.
So I'm doing this and-
- It's not like driving
ends well, definitely.
- No. We get to the fifth day.
I'm like so ready to like book the test?
He's like, no. I was like, what you mean?
He's like, you're not ready yet.
Not ready, I'm like, what do you mean?
There's like five days guarantee.
He's like you're gonna
fail right now if you do it
and I'm like, oh, well what do we do then?
He's like, well, sits
back like he loves it.
He's like, yeah well you know,
you could pay me in cash
and I'll give you some private lessons,
you know and I was like, oh,
I was like is that okay?
He's like, yeah it's okay.
- According to me.
(all laughing)
- And he was like, conveniently
like really expensive.
But I was like well shit,
I need him to say yes, so that I can
'cause they won't do it
without him saying yes.
- So you literally bribed him?
- No, no, no, he kind of blackmailed him.
- Like I've no choice.
'Cause I can't do the
lesson without him agreeing.
So I was like, oh and I was
like, well, when do we do it?
'Cause I kind of wanna get
this over and done with,
I gotta go do America in like a week,
I wanted to like get this done.
He was like, oh, well
are you free tomorrow?
And I was like, yeah, I'm free tomorrow.
And he was like, all right well meet me
in this car park tomorrow
and we'll do like three hours
and then we'll see how you do it.
So I pay him in an
extortion amount of money,
you know and then we do the three hours,
he's like all right now you're ready.
And I'm like, yeah I better have to.
- [Joey] of course you're ready now.
- I was like, you probably just let me
drove around for the hours.
So isn't it legally a bribe or something.
So he finally does it and
the way that this works
normally in the UK, if you wanna test,
I don't know how it's in Australia,
but you have to wait like a month.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because I don't know how they do it,
but this company has like
an in with the government
where basically like, if anyone cancels,
they get all those reservations.
So you basically have to just be ready.
And they'll be like, are you
free tomorrow to do the test?
So that's what happened.
So I said, I'm ready to get the test.
And then like one day
later they were like,
come to this place at this time,
the teacher will be there.
And I was like, oh shit this
is fucking nerve wrecking.
- No, we have to go to
like, for all of our tests,
you have to go to like
a government certified
like road in Maritime, so this is-
- Oh no, we did, we did.
You have to do it as well,
you have to do as well,
D well thing.
So I go to this building and it's like
the official government
building is above like a salon.
Like it's in this really
weird, like beat up room.
It's just one room.
- What?
- And like, there's like
seven other people in here.
And I just turn off and I'm like,
what the fuck, it's weird.
It looks like some government building,
like doesn't look, it's
just above like a salad
and chicken shop.
So I go in and they're
like, did you park the car?
So there's no car park
in this place either,
you park on the street.
Oh, so I'm parked on a hill upwards.
- Right, right, right.
- And so I'm on like a
brink before, like a-
- You're on manual, right?
- Yeah manual. Yeah.
So I'm parked on a hill
right before roundabout
and it's a really busy jewel carriageway.
This is awful, right?
- That's like nightmare fuel.
- This is literally like the worst.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- So I'm bricking it,
and this guy can tell I'm freaking out.
'Cause this is a horrible start.
If you let it roll back at all,
like you fall down the hill, you fail.
And normally like most
driving, like things,
you might not even have to do this thing
when you start from a hill.
So I was like shit, because my instructor,
the decided to park here,
this is where I had to stop.
So I was like fuck.
So you know, I'm doing it.
And I'm nearly fucking,
I let go of the break
and I'm just not moving,
I'm lucky maintaining it.
And I slowly start to
creep and then fucking lory
just go (screaming) and like goes past me,
I'm ah, like freaking out.
I'm like holding onto the
clutch like not letting it go.
'Cause I don't wanna go and
I don't wanna fall down.
I'm just like sweating and he's like,
mate, calm down mate, what you doing?
Don't worry about it and I'm
like, he's like prop London.
And I was like, yeah thanks
man I'm real calm now.
Luckily I get going, it's really easy,
you know and everything's going well,
and this guy looks like
he's falling asleep.
He's literally like this on the window.
And I'm like, what the fuck.
And I did a thing where I thought I failed
and I was freaking out,
cause I thought I failed halfway through
and I go through the end
and I passed, I did
like one minor mistake.
That was all I had.
Don't know how.
Because on the way to the
test, I ran a red light.
I did all things wrong and
everything went terribly.
And then yeah, weirdly at the end of it,
my instructor came with the
guy who was like really weird.
He came over and he was
like, thought you failed.
and I was like, why would you say that?
He's like you know how I
knew, I thought you failed.
And I was like, how?
And he's like, you know,
when the guy opens the door
before he gives the news,
it's only a bad sign.
I'm like, why would that be a bad sign?
Why does that make any sense?
I don't understand, so he can run away.
- Why is he like tryna like psychoanalyze?
- It sound like a dick head as a fuck.
- He was such a dick bro.
- I got a really nice instructor.
He was like a proud dad.
He was like, I knew you'd pass.
But the thing is the thing-
- My dad was my instructor.
- Your dad was you instructor?
- Yeah, because in Australia,
when you're on your learners,
you don't have to go to
lessons if you don't want.
- No, you don't have to in the UK either.
It's just like my parents.
- So my parents were like,
no, that's fucking expensive.
You're not gonna lessons.
My dad's like, son I'll teach you.
And I was like, dad, you are literally
the most crazy fucking driver I've known.
- Yeah, because most
people, when they drive,
they don't drive like
how they, 100% should.
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- My parents won't teach me.
'Cause they were like,
we're probably not doing
something's right ourselves.
- I was like, dad, we're
in an eighties zone
and I'm doing a hundred is this okay?
And he was like, and he was like, no,
it's like, no, everyone else is doing it.
They can't arrest all of us.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] That's true.
- That's true, that's fair enough.
- Can I do this in the test?
- No, don't do it in the
test, but you'll be right now.
- Driving is way more fun
when you've passed your test.
'Cause you're like,
okay I can kind of like relax.
- It's like, oh, this
is like, what is like
driving stress less.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I actually remember the first time
I was like in the seat of a car actually.
So in the driver's seat
of a car was actually
when I was about like,
I think like 12 or 13.
So like, I remember like there was one day
where I think there was
like a friend of a cousin
who was just like, you know,
he was like very rich.
So he's they like, their family
owned like a lot of land.
And so on some of this land
that they owned, right.
They let their kid drive around a car.
It was like a beaten up car.
It was a beaten up car.
And I remember going to this place once
and he was like driving on his field.
I was like, dude, this is badass.
And he was like, you wanna go?
Wanna go? And I was like me, me?
12 Years old driving a car. Am I allowed?
- Can you even see out the front?
- Am I allowed to do that?
Am I allowed to do that?
He was like, yeah, it's
private land it's legal.
And I was like-
- 12 year old
knew the concept of
private land and legal.
Yeah, of course Article 1349.
- Well that's what his dad told him.
And so I'm like I go in the driver's seat
and I saw like fucking shitting myself.
'Cause I'm just like I'm in a fucking car.
- Old choice, like a 12 year old driver.
- As a 12 year old in the seat of a car,
it doesn't matter if
you're like driving a Jeep
or a mini, it's like operating a goundou.
It's terrifying.
- It is terrifying.
So I remember the first
fucking thing I did.
And he was just like, oh,
just tap the pedal a bit.
As a 12 year old, I dunno
what tapped means, right.
And so I'm just like, I
go, what I think, is like,
I thought tapping, it was
going 50% of the weight.
- You do, you do, you do.
- So I'm like, okay,
I'm going to tap this.
I'm not gonna put it all
the way, just half the way,
like immediately
- Wheels start spinning.
- I put it half the weight
and I immediately crash into
his gates, right.(laughing)
- No.
- Luckily it's like an old wooden gate
and it's like in the middle
of fucked up nowhere,
immediately I smashed
into this gate, right.
And I start freaking out and he was like,
right get outta driver's seat. (laughing)
- [Joey] Never again.
- And like, I think
that put me off driving,
like for like, well obviously I was scared
of the concept of driving
from that one experience.
- I think I remember that.
Like the first time I
ever got into the car seat
was probably around that
age as well, like 12, 13.
When we went camping.
And like, you know,
because you're in a camping field, right.
Not a lot of like, and
especially when you're in a
big camping field and
there's no one else there,
it's just a lot of like
really empty, flat land.
So my dad was like, son, you
wanna take it for a spin?
And I was like, sure dad,
and I get in the seat
and in my head I'm like,
yeah, this is gonna be easy.
There's literally nothing
around except one tree.
- [Garnt And Connor] No.
- But like any, any person will tell you,
it's like, just don't go towards the tree.
Just go to this entire open
area where there is nothing.
And in my head I was like, okay,
just don't go over to the tree.
What do I do immediately
go towards the tree.
- Did your dad not like pull the wheel?
- Oh yeah, he did.
- Oh, okay.
- He was like, son.
- Did you hit it?
- No, I didn't.
Oh my God, dude. I wouldn't
be alive if I hit the tree.
- Yeah, I think my dad would kill me.
- Yeah, my dad would have
hundred percent killed.
But like I don't know what it was,
it was like in my stupid 12 year old head,
the entire time I was like,
don't go towards the tree,
don't go towards the tree.
My hands are like, go towards trees, okay.
- It's like a homing missile.
- It's like target locked on.
- I actually flipped my
friend's quad bike over.
- [Joey] Oh my that's dangerous.
- Yeah, that was dangerous.
We were riding quad bikes in like the mud.
And I was like, this is
the coolest fucking thing.
And like, you know, I was like 12
and then he was like
don't go too fast though.
And I was like a danger kid.
I would just like, love going
too fast and shit like that.
And yeah.
- I think they also call
that an idiot. (laughing)
- I should won a Darwin award back day.
And so I'm like fucking
this fucking quad bike.
I start doing like donuts
with this quad bike
and then yeah, it just flips over.
And I flip in it, but
I'm so small that like,
I like get down in the arch
and like, when I fall to the
side, like don't hit my head
or anything, just fall over.
- 'Cause, like, yeah.
I think like quad bike
accidents, like deaths,
are very common.
- Yeah it wasn't like super fast.
It was just me being stupid and turning
but fault I just fell off.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah. Dumb, dumb, dangerous, dangerous.
- Yeah. Don't do that.
- Don't flip quad bikes.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause like, I remember like, I never,
like I knew one person in my school
who owned like a quad bike
and he was like the
fucking cool kid, right.
- If you have like farms, everyone,
like a lot of people had them.
- Yeah, I mean like the only reason
this guy had a quad bike
or this kid had a quad bike
was because his dad had
won the lottery, right.
So he was like.
- (laughing) why is it
when you get too rich
you buy a quad bike.
There's no practical use
for a quad bike, right.
- It's just to have, isn't it.
- If you have too much
land, you get a quad bike,
so you can get around the land.
- Yeah. So he was just like,
he was the cool kid because he was the kid
that owned a quad bike.
And like, it was like the kid that
like you'd want to be friends
because you'd knew like you'd made it
when he'd invite you around his house.
'Cause like, you'd hear
stories about how people
went to this kid's house and
like I went on a quad bike.
- Yeah, it's either that one
kid that owns a quad bike
or that one kid whose dad
works in an IT company
and owns every game console ever.
Everyone had that one friend.
- My friend was both.
- [Joey] Oh really? Oh my God.
- His dad was a farmer, so
he had all the quad bike
and all that stuff.
But he also had all the game consoles
and I always used to love going.
'Cause he had Pokemon
call on the game cube.
And I was like, this is insane.
You can, the Pokemon are
like three. What, what?
So we'd have a day of like quad biking
and then his mom would make amazing food
and then I'd to play on soon.
Yeah and so I just like never
wanted to leave his house.
And luckily like I
slept over to his house,
so many god damn times and I
loved staying at his house.
- I had that one friend
too. That was like that.
- It was amazing, we had so much fun.
I loved going to his house.
That was like the best child of memories.
Except when I nearly died on
that quad back, of course.
That was my own fault.
- That's fair enough.
- But quad bikes are fun though.
There was really, they're so fun.
They're pretty easy to drive.
- Have I been on one?
I don't think I have been on one actually.
- It's like a stable bike.
- Until it flips over.
- Yeah. (indistinct)
So like we used to go to like,
you know what I was saying
about like the kayaking thing?
There was another place that
was kind of a similar thing,
had like swimming pool and all that.
And it also had quad bikes.
That you were allowed to ride,
but they put like safety
pins or something in it.
That limited the speed.
So you couldn't go above a certain speed
and it was painfully slow.
And one of the kids
who owned the quad bike
knew how to remove it.
And then we were all doing laps, right.
Going really slow on these bikes
suddenly is this one kid's turn.
And the teachers like
looked away for a second
and they go back, this kid's going like
fucking tearing up all the like dirt,
flinging it at all the teachers and stuff,
like absolutely tearing up the track
and they couldn't stop him.
'Cause he's going too fast.
Like you couldn't like get in the way.
And so he is going super fast
to get to the ball king of his life.
But it was so funny just watching him like
destroy this like gland
that had been finally made.
He was like tearing up the mud and shit.
- [Joey] Destroy it all.
- So funny.
- Do you guys have any experiences
with motorbikes or anything like that?
- No. I wish I'd love
to drive a motorbike.
- I've been on the back
of a motorbike many times,
but it's scary.
- It's fucking terrifying.
- I wanna learn how to ride one.
- I've thought about it.
But then I've also heard
of every single person
I've ever known who
used to ride a motorbike
is it's all past tense.
They used to ride a motorbike
because most of the time they
get in horrible accidents.
- I just wanna ride one. I just
wanna know how to drive one.
What if I'm like, I just need
to ride a motorcycle one day.
- I was tempted to get like in Japan,
like getting like a motorbike license.
Because apparently you can
get it in like one day.
It's like super easy.
You just have to do like a test
and if you pay like 60 bucks or something.
- [Joey and Connor] 60, 60, 60, 60.
- You pay like 60 bucks for a test
and then you can just get it
in like a couple of hours.
They just have to buy a motorbike.
- If you like James Bond, chase,
you need to drive a motorcycle. you know.
- I'm gonna drive a moped.
(indistinct chattering)
- Stop you immediately like
Joey where you going man?
- 'Cause like if you go to Thailand,
you are probably going to
have to ride a motorcycle.
And when I say motorcycle,
it's not like a Harley Davidson
or something.
It's the Southeast Asian like
kind of like Moped motorcycles
where it's like,
- [Joey] like a scooter right?
- Like a scooter. Yeah.
- I thought motocross is
really cool as well right?
- Yeah like that kind of bike, I guess.
Yeah, but like I've been
on enough fucking crazy ass
fucking Moped motorbike taxi drivers.
That is just put me off
from ever wanting to learn
a motorbike.
And like the one time
that I tried learning
how to ride a motorbike,
which was one of these bikes,
mind you.
And I remember, of course
it was in Thailand.
And like, I remember like,
if you want to get around,
but not want to own a car,
then you'd learn to drive a motorcycle.
That's the cheap way to go about it.
I mean, that's why in top gear
and the Vietnam special,
they didn't have cars.
They had motorbikes, right.
- Do they get stolen a lot?
- Huh?
- I assume I've never owned
one. So I would assume so.
- Probably.
- But like I remember like the only time
I've tried to learn how to ride one
I've had like enough scary
experience with motorbikes
that I've just never wanted
to learn how to ride one.
And I remember when my dad was just like,
come on, son you gotta
learn how to drive one,
come on we're in Thailand.
You gotta learn how to
drive one eventually.
And I remember he like
builds this ideal up,
my entire family, like build this idea up
of me having to like,
at least give it a try
of how to learn, how to ride a motorbike.
And I remember this one
time I was like, okay, fine.
I'll give it a try, I'll give it a try.
It's just like riding a bike, right.
Just like riding a bike.
And it was like a one for one recreation
of like my car experience, right.
Because I remember my
dad after building up
all this courage, we have
like my cousin's motor bike
that I could try out and
just start learning with.
And my dad like brings me over to the bike
and goes, okay, just
sit on this bike, okay.
And what you need to do. Just try-
- Your dad like give you
that much confidence.
He's like stuck you on it.
- He stuck me on it and he's just like,
just twisted a bit, just twist it a bit.
Just give it a bit of a rev
and me like a one for one thinking
a little bit of a twist is 50%.
(all laughing)
- Garnt, you can't like do this.
You can only do like 50%.
- And so 50% means 180 degrees.
- So I go like, okay,
I'll give a little twist.
50% power.
Like that immediately rev forward.
I immediately fall down
and like, the motorbike falls down on me.
I'm like, alright, no, I'm
never getting on one again.
- I'm just reminded of all those videos
of like where they, thank you.
Where they like rev the motorbikes
and then motorbike comes over them.
- I dunno, I really wanna learn, like,
I don't know, like a lot
of dangerous vehicles.
I'd love to learn how to drive.
I really wanna learn how
to drive a speedboat.
I don't know why, I've
never even been in a,
like a speedboat.
- I've been in a speedboat
and it's terrifying.
- I just wanna learn how to
drive one, that look so fun.
- Because in Australia
or at least in Sydney,
we used to have like,
we had like a fairy service
because we were like in a bay.
But you'd also get,
what's called a water cat,
which is basically think of like,
it's a taxi.
- I think I know.
- Like a water taxi, but
it's instead of a taxi
it's speedboat.
- I think I know the one.
- And you get on boat, dude
those things are fucking scary.
- They look so fun.
- They're so fast.
- Like, I wanna ride a jet ski.
I've never rid jet ski in my life.
- I wanna ride a jet ski.
I've heard jet skis are fun.
- That's like the
college fra boy ass hole.
I just wanna ride one. It looks so fun.
- Let's do it in Thailand.
It's very, very easy to
get jet skis in Thailand.
- I remember I sure a sheet that was like,
it was like accidents
by race or something.
It was like 100% of accident,
like some part of the U.S
was like all white people or something.
And it was for jet ski.
100% of jet ski accidents
for white people.
And I was like, yeah, that makes sense.
(all laughing)
- That checks out.
- I think the second was
like skiing or something.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Okay.
- [Joey] What's third golf?
- I've always wanted to try surfing.
Surfing was one thing
I've always wanted to try.
- I've done surfing and-
- It seems hard.
- Of course you're Australian, Joey.
- I thought I would enjoy
it, but I weirdly didn't.
- It seems really hard.
- It's really, really hard.
It's not even so much about like,
you know, it's not like snowboarding
where like the biggest
obstacle is your being scared
to just like go fast or whatever.
It's literally just like,
it's the act of standing
up from a really like
rickety, like where the
floor isn't still right.
And you do that a couple of times
and you can't even like, get on your knees
and then you fucking fall over
and then you just snap.
You're like, fuck it. I can't do it.
Because like the one time you
can actually like stand up.
It's actually pretty easy to control.
Because just think of it
like snowboarding board
with less friction.
So it's pretty easy to do.
It's the standing up part,
that's like fucking impossible for me.
I don't know what it is.
And then when you flip
in a surfboard, it hurts.
- [Connor] Yeah I can imagine.
- Because the one I'm
always afraid of is like,
what if I flip off and then
the board just smacks on.
Like I've seen that happen to people
and it looks like it really fucking hurts.
- Seeing them ride that wave
is just so fucking cool.
I really wanna do it again
I've never had the opportunity.
- I've never had the opportunity.
Like, cause we live in the England,
where are we gonna find waves?
I could go to Corn Wall I know.
- The waves there are way too powerful
or like nothing.
- I think that was the problem as well.
'Cause we did it for PE at one time
because our school was right-
- [Garnt] That's the most
Australian thing I've ever heard.
- Oh because our schooling-
- [Garnt] Surfing for PE.
- 'Cause our school is
literally next to a beach.
So we just like walk down
five minutes down the hill
and it's like, yeah,
there's a beach right there.
You can go surf.
- [Connor] Of course there is.
- Yeah, but it was scary
dude for a different reason.
- That's so cool, man. I
wish I could, I wish I could.
- Lots, of first we wanna
try, you wanna try golf?
You wanna try sailing.
- Surfing.
- Surfing and sailing.
I wanna try quad biking.
- I wanna try them all actually.
- Yeah. I wanna try them all.
- Can we just have like
a sports festival day
for Trash Taste? (laughing)
- I just wanna try to like-
- Get all these things in one place.
- I just wanna try more
like extreme sports.
You know what I mean.
- You tried skiing now you got
taste for the extreme, right?
- Yeah. I got a taste of
adrenaline you know that's-
- [Staff] Bungee jumping.
- Bungee jumping.
I'm still waiting for Chris.
- But you know who else
likes extreme sports?
Our patrons.
- [Garnt] Of course.
- [Connor] Really, do they?
- I dunno.
- They're just so daring.
They dared enough to support the boys.
- That is the most extreme sport.
- To support a podcast.
- Supporting the boys.
- Getting your wallet out.
Getting your wallet out.
That's the hardest sport.
- Thinking, yeah these
guys are worth my money.
That's the most extreme sport.
- We do appreciate. We do appreciate.
- Yeah, so thank you.
And if you would like to support the show,
then go to our Patreon,
peton.com/trashtaste
also follow us on Twitter,
send some memes on the sore
and if you heard our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And what kind of extreme
sport would you like to try?
I feel like this pandemic
like era has just like
made people want to just like try sport
at least for me anyway.
- Yeah cause I think one
of the biggest things
about trying new sport is just getting,
like getting the motivation,
just go out of your comfort zone
and just try out a new sport.
- It definitely helps when you have a like
your mates around and be
like, yeah, I'll try with you.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
Like I dunno if I could
do snowboarding by myself
because I just feel like,
- Yeah, it's hard.
- It's a sad image of just like one person
just sitting in the fucking
thing going up, right.
It's like, oh.
(all laughing and humming)
- Anyway, that's been this
episode of Trash Taste.
- See you guys next week. I guess.
- Bye bye.
(light upbeat music)